[主播] 唐老师，董老师，冰老师，都可以啊。
[主播] 欢迎欢迎，欢迎董老师。
[主播] 各位朋友们，大家晚上好啊。
[主播] 现在我声音正常吗？
[主播] OK,谢谢，谢谢。
[主播] 好，谢谢。晚上好啊。
[主播] 有朋友说让东东老师回来。
[主播] 让东东老师休息一会。
[主播] 真的让东东回来。
[主播] 让东东这种帅哥多出现在我们面前几次。
[主播] 大家现在对我的要求已经越来越苛刻了。
[主播] 现在说董宇辉来吃了，请扣工资。
[主播] 我们还记下了。
[主播] 还帮我记下了。
[主播] 现在要把我法办了是吧？
[主播] 好。
[主播] 当年一起看星星的时候叫人家小甜甜啊，现在新人胜旧人。
[主播] 要把人家法办了。
[主播] 行吧。
[主播] 错付了啊。
[主播] 我们今天晚上的书很多。
[主播] 今天晚上的这个也有一些好的产品。
[主播] 美的窒息的唐诗宋词诗经一共有十万单。
[主播] 这个吗？
[主播] 真好。
[主播] 来，这本书直播间里的朋友之前没有拍过的，大家可以继续拍了。
[主播] 顿顿这两天给大家读了很多的诗经。
[主播] 喜欢的朋友可以拿着这个，买着这个书呢，等顿顿跟大家一起去读诗经。
[主播] 我特别喜欢喜欢这个唐诗宋词啊，因为我这个。
[主播] 确实是文化水平有限，文化有限公司嘛。
[主播] 文化水平有限。
[主播] 所以呢，这个诗经呢我确实读的少一些。
[主播] 但是我对于唐诗宋词还是比较喜欢的。
[主播] 许渊冲老师的。
[主播] 之前也给大家讲过他很多的这种翻译。
[主播] 其中像这里头非常经典的春江花月夜，张若虚。
[主播] 大家读到春江花月夜的时候，觉得真的。
[主播] 是怎么写出这样的绝篇。
[主播] 你在后来很难再能找到一个篇幅如此长，但是每一句都有惊艳到意向描述的准确到让人拍案叫绝的一首诗。
[主播] 春江潮水连海平，海上明月共潮生。
[主播] 燕燕随波千万里，何处春江。
[主播] 无月明。
[主播] 你注意你注意他的这个措辞。
[主播] 写得真好呀。
[主播] The Moon over the River on a Spring Night。
[主播] 当然这个很长啊，后面我就不给大家全部读完了。
[主播] 因为后面这个大家都知道，我就经典的说。
[主播] 江畔何人初见月，江月何年初照人。
[主播] 人生代代无穷已。
[主播] 江月年年只相似。
[主播] 后面给你翻译的： In spring, the river rises as high as the sea。
[主播] And with the river's tide uprises the moon bright。
[主播] She follows the rolling waves for ten thousand li。
[主播] 里嘛，千里嘛，十万里啊，十千里就一万里。
[主播] Where the river flows, there overflows her light。
[主播] 许老师的翻译有的时侯。
[主播] 你等我一个纸，我把桌子擦一下。
[主播] 我把书弄脏了。
[主播] 许老师的翻译呢，很多时候就是让人感觉到拍案叫绝。
[主播] 就是你也不知道他到底有怎么样灵巧的那个思路。
[主播] 他正好就在那块能想到那个词。
[主播] 晚辈愚钝啊。
[主播] 晚辈曾经在大学的时候也常，先给我一个湿巾。
[主播] 我先擦湿再擦，这样才能干净。
[主播] 你这个就放在这里，给。
[主播] 我曾经在大学的时候把许老的翻译看过无数遍。
[主播] 越看觉得越绝。
[主播] 越看越觉得，不行，真的不行。
[主播] 相思，王维。
[主播] 红豆生南国，春来发几枝。
[主播] 愿君多采撷，此物最相思。
[主播] 当然这首诗大家都听过。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 你听过王维的。
[主播] 什么？
[主播] 红豆嘛，是吧？
[主播] 前一段相思嘛，是吧？
[嘉宾] 听过王维的相思。
[主播] 你听过王维的相思吗？
[主播] 前一段好像这是一个梗。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 然后呢，这首诗也翻译的是真的好。
[主播] 说 The red beans grow in Southern land。
[主播] How many load in spring the trees。
[主播] Gather them to full is your hand。
[主播] They will revive found memories。
[主播] 你看 Spring the trees。
[主播] Revive found memories。
[主播] In Southern land is your hand。
[主播] 他把音压的就非常好。
[主播] 许老的这个唐诗宋词诗经一共现在有十万册。
[主播] 如果说之前没有拍到的朋友，请自己去拍一单。
[主播] 这三本书我是强烈建议每一个人家里都应该有一套的。
[主播] 它的好处在于什么？
[主播] 第一个，首先上面是这个古诗。
[主播] 大家可以看到孩子在家里面的时候就可以先背诗。
[主播] 小的时候熟读唐诗三百首。
[主播] 不会作诗也能吟。
[主播] 先大量的去背。
[主播] 背的多了，他长大的时候就自然有了人文气息。
[主播] 大家这两天喜欢顿顿，张嘴就来。
[主播] 因为他有大量的记忆库，他有大量的输入呀。
[主播] 然后呢，下面你看，还有这个对应的英文的翻译。
[主播] 这是许老的翻译。
[主播] 许老的翻译真的狠经典啊。
[主播] 他经典到不可多得。
[主播] 很多时候我们去听许老的翻译，真的就是拍案叫绝。
[主播] 我我之前给大家应该分享过。
[主播] 我当年在大学就一开始什么时候对许老的翻译开始感觉到就是晚辈真的愚鲁一生可能难以忘怀，望其项背的时候。
[主播] 第一个拿听过那个叫道可道非常。
[主播] 非常。
[主播] 它不应该那样停顿啊。
[主播] 它不是道可道非常道。
[主播] 它应该说道可道非长道。
[主播] 不是普通的道理。
[主播] 然后许老师怎么翻译的呢？
[主播] 叫做 Truth。
[主播] Can be known。
[主播] 说真理是可以被人知道的。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 后来格物致知。
[主播] 真理是可以被知道的。
[主播] 真理不知道是在你内心还是在这个外面嘈杂的时间动，但是总之啊，真理是可以被知道的。
[主播] Truth can be known。
[主播] But。
[主播] It may not be the well-known truth。
[主播] 你注意这就是翻译的灵巧啊。
[主播] 如果是故弄玄虚的人，他一定会让自己显得复杂高深一些。
[主播] 他一定遣词造句是咬文嚼字，哎呀，一些。
[主播] 有的那种复杂已经到了闭帚自珍的状况了。
[主播] 就有人觉得你看我这用词多么高级。
[主播] 我的句式多么的复杂。
[主播] But no, that's not the point of any composition。
[主播] That's not the point of any translation or interpretation, okay?
[主播] To make words simple。
[主播] And you will make the language beautiful。
[主播] 就一定不是复杂让人感到美。
[主播] 我们说大道至简。
[主播] 谁跟你说过大道至杂呢？
[主播] 复杂的东西是很难被人所理解的。
[主播] 就它精致的像一朵花，但它没有香那种感觉。
[主播] 所以你看道可道非常道说真理是可以被大家所知道的。
[主播] 但可能不是为人所熟知的这个真理。
[主播] 我好多年前就看过许老翻译这块。
[主播] 我看完之后我觉得。
[主播] 就是你看他没有用复杂的词，对吗？
[主播] 他也没有给你用非常夸张的翻译，对吗？
[主播] 他没有故意用一些让人感觉到听不懂的东西，对吗？
[主播] 但是他却把这个意思传达的很清晰很准确。
[主播] 这就是比例。
[主播] 叫四两拨千斤。
[主播] 如果说中文是古文，我也把英语翻译的非常复杂，那反而可能就走错了。
[主播] 所以我后来在读英语或者看很多翻译的这个思路就真的是早些年受到了许老的影响。
[主播] 所以。
[主播] 小时候受到好的美的影响。
[主播] 你长大就能真正的去审视美。
[主播] 语言就是一种美。
[主播] 这个世界的美有千万种。
[主播] 这个世界的美包括天体行星宇宙万物的美。
[主播] 我们皆是宇宙星辰的孩子。
[主播] 我们既然生如蝼蚁而美若星辰，美若神明。
[主播] 那星辰也美若神明。
[主播] 这个世界还有很多美，比如说大江大河。
[主播] 比如说山川湖泊的美。
[主播] 自然界的美，它往往是难以复制的。
[主播] 所以人为什么会亲自然性？
[主播] 因为微观到原子层面，我们跟他们都一样。
[主播] 这个世界还有很多的美，比如说花红柳绿，比如说草长莺飞。
[主播] 人间三月天，牵你爱人的手去看春天的河边。
[主播] 我不知道你有没有真的去过春天的河边，万物焕发生机的样子。
[主播] 那种美可以是去年今日此门中，人面桃花相映红。
[主播] 是那种美。
[主播] 我们还有其他更多的美。
[主播] 比如说三餐四季，只短情长的美。
[主播] 比如说那种细腻，细碎，细小，但是常常让你暖心，安心，自或放心的那些美，也有可能。
[主播] 美还有一种就是刚才给大家所展示的这种语言的美。
[主播] 对吧？而且我我我第一次给大家提到许老师，我提到的他那个翻译，就是好多年前在西安西安外国语大学的图书馆里头。
[主播] 我坐在了一楼的地上，头顶的空调吹下来，我一开始我觉得很燥热。
[主播] 但读到那句翻译的时候，我突然觉得自己汗毛都起来了。
[主播] 因为我觉得这个翻译太牛了。
[主播] 就是大家听过的，不爱红装爱武装。
[主播] 因为那会儿我确实英语水平差的很远。
[主播] 叫 not to powder the face。
[主播] But to face the powder。
[主播] 他就把两个词动名词性互换就行了。
[主播] Powder大家都学过。
[主播] 名词叫什么呀？
[主播] 粉末。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 那你是不是引申为，比如说脸上涂的这种脂粉。
[主播] 脸上涂的这种。
[主播] 脂粉是这个写吗？是这样，脂粉是这样写吗？
[主播] 脂肪的脂是这样写吗？
[嘉宾] 是脂粉。
[主播] OK,不好意思，我中文。
[主播] 脂粉或者是我们所说的火药其实也可以吧。
[主播] 那动词就是。
[主播] 给什么什么施粉。
[主播] 然后呢， Face大家也学过。
[主播] Face什么意思啊？
[主播] 名词叫做脸。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 或者什么的表面。
[主播] 比如说 the face of the Earth,地球的表面。
[主播] 那动词呢就叫做面对。
[主播] Okay, you're gonna face difficulties in your life eventually。
[主播] 你肯定会在生活中面对很多的困难的。
[主播] 所以注意它的翻译。
[主播] 叫不要去给脸上涂脂粉，叫不爱红装。
[主播] 而是去面对这个火药，叫爱武装。
[主播] 就狠神。
[主播] 这就狠神。
[主播] 所以这就是为什么这三本书需要值得你去买。
[主播] 好书值得买。
[主播] 好书甚至值得收藏。
[主播] 我觉得这几套书不仅你自己可以看，你自己甚至可以把它留给自己的子孙去看。
[主播] 这套书我们刚上第一天我就拍了。
[主播] 我拍了三套。
[主播] 我自己留了一套。
[主播] 我给别人也送了两套。
[主播] 比如翻到这里，蜀相杜甫。
[主播] 李白的偶像是什么？
[主播] 李白的偶像是武将。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 十步杀一人，千里不留行。
[主播] 杜甫的偶像是谁？
[主播] 杜甫的偶像是诸葛亮。
[主播] 所以他写的蜀相大家都知道吧？
[主播] 丞相祠前何处寻，锦官城外柏森森。
[主播] 映阶碧草自春色，隔叶黄鹂空好音。
[主播] 三顾频繁天下计。
[主播] 两朝开济老臣心。
[主播] 最后两句话大家都听过。
[主播] 叫做出身未捷身先死。
[主播] 常使英雄泪满襟。
[主播] Temple of the Premier of the Shu。
[主播] 蜀就是蜀国啊。
[主播] Premier。
[主播] It's like the Prime Minister, like the highest position in the government。
[主播] It's kind of, yeah。
[主播] The Premier's temple is in the shade。
[主播] Surprise woven with brocade。
[主播] The steps are green with grass in spring。
[主播] In vain, a may leaves all real saying。
[主播] Cloud, proud。
[主播] Why should the Mongol flute complain a willow grow。
[主播] Beyond the gate of Jade, the wind will blow。
[主播] 你看。
[主播] 怨杨柳。
[主播] 为什么抱怨没有柳树在生长呢？
[主播] 后面说因为没有春风能够吹过来。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 好像我们小时候学这个杨柳的叶子细小都是吹风给从树枝里抽出来的一样。
[主播] 剪出来的一样。
[主播] 这就是翻译的这个灵巧之处啊。
[主播] 春风不度玉门关。
[主播] 就吹不到这里。
[主播] 太平洋的水气好像吹不到这里一样。
[主播] 今天晚上我们是不是有橄榄油啊？
[嘉宾] 有。
[主播] 我昨天晚上睡着了，我觉得我今天晚上应该能写几个小作文。
[主播] 我今天晚上状态很好。
[主播] 能看出来吗？
[嘉宾] 可以，看得出来。
[主播] 能看出来是吧？
[嘉宾] 是的。
[主播] 好。
[主播] 我再讲一会儿书。
[主播] 等我们人数到多的时候。
[嘉宾] 可以，对。
[嘉宾] 看看这几本你哪个敢讲。
[主播] 活着。
[主播] 经典数目反复讲。
[主播] 如果说连这种经典的我都推荐不出去，那说明我确实不够好。
[主播] 不是书不好。
[主播] 是学生的比例不到。
[主播] 是晚辈的能力不够。
[主播] 我们为什么要审视苦难？
[主播] 因为我们要寻求美好。
[主播] 只有见过黑暗的人才会渴望光明。
[主播] 只有身患重症的人才尤其的渴望健康。
[主播] 只有经历挫折的人才懂得平淡是真。
[主播] 这就是为什么在现在生活感觉已经很好的时候，人们要去审视苦难。
[主播] 审视苦难的本质是让你知道如何过好自己这短暂的一生啊。
[主播] 当你的生命有一天感觉没有什么能够值得去寄托的时候，我们要如何继续前行？
[主播] 这一句话，我认为可以比较从一个概括的角度去总结这本书。
[主播] 家人一个一个离开。
[主播] 家产也散尽。
[主播] 自己就只剩下了一个残缺的，疾病的，年迈的身体的时候，福贵要怎么过完他这一生？
[主播] 苦难的人会看到苦难。
[主播] 但透过苦难，人类会看到生命的底色。
[主播] 我们自从远古时代时期，人一直就在与苦难做斗争。
[主播] 但是，我始终相信人是一种充满了力量感的生物。
[主播] 要不然我们也不可能坚持到今天。
[主播] 大家能理解在环境极度困难的时候。
[主播] 在生活极度艰难的时候。
[主播] 在命运极其坎坷的时候。
[主播] 我们总是能够想办法熬下来，对吗？
[主播] 你说是吗？
[主播] 总是可以的。
[主播] 余华老师大家不知道吗？
[主播] 许三观卖血记。
[主播] 没看过？
[主播] 活着没看过？
[主播] 如果没有看过的话，请大家，这个后来就，对，他曾经被改编成电影和电视剧。
[主播] 福贵们大家听过吗？
[主播] 我我之前给大家讲过一个啊。
[主播] 就是当你生命失无可失的时候，请你永远要坦坦荡荡的，充满勇气的去过好自己的这一生，不为别的，因为你的生命属于你自己。
[主播] 今夜我不爱世人，今夜我独爱你。
[主播] 这应该是孩子写的一句诗。
[主播] 是吗？
[嘉宾] 是的。
[主播] 我没有记错的话，今夜我不爱世人，今夜我独爱你。
[主播] 如果没有记错的话，应该是孩子写的诗。
[主播] 今夜我不爱世人，今夜我独爱你。
[主播] 大家可以把这句话发到评论区，今夜我不爱世人，今夜我独爱你。
[主播] 为什么我突然想给大家说这句话，今夜我不爱世人，今夜我独爱你，因为我们有太多的原因去脆弱了。
[主播] 对吗？
[主播] 去投降了。
[主播] Never surrender to the fate。
[主播] 今夜我不关心人类，我只想着你。
[主播] OK, OK,原话这么说的。
[主播] 不好意思啊。
[主播] 今夜我不关心人类，我只想着你，是吧？
[主播] 嗯嗯。
[主播] 我说错了。
[主播] 孩子的原诗不是这样子。
[主播] 今夜我不关心人类，我只想着你。
[主播] 我觉得我刚是那个我不爱世人，我只爱你，也行。
[主播] 我觉得也挺好的。
[嘉宾] 是一种延伸。
[主播] 对不起，虽然我做错了，但是我这个将错就错。
[主播] 人生难得躺平，像我这种将错就错的想得很开。
[主播] 我为什么会这么说呢？因为大家生活。
[主播] 江错就错。人生难得躺平。
[主播] 像我这种江错就错的，想得很开。
[主播] 我为什么会这么说呢？因为大家生活中最上会遇到不快了嘛，对吧？
[主播] 我希望你快乐。
[主播] 然后呢，这个因为最近我火了之后，很多人把董宇辉当成了一个关系很好的朋友，向他倾诉内心的这个愁苦。
[主播] 我其实收到很多的消息，但我真的第一个我看不完，第二个我也回不完。
[主播] 我前两天拿了手机，大家知道，因为我这个抖音睡一觉起来涨几十万粉丝，睡一觉涨四五十万粉丝。
[主播] 都在给我发消息。
[主播] 我的手机折一打开抖音，屏幕就变白了，就发烫，就关机了，就自动关机了。
[主播] 我姐姐应该是听到了，很心疼我，给我寄了一个新的手机过来，还挺感动的。
[主播] 我这两天收到了好几个莫名的快递，挺感动的。
[主播] 然后我以为是谁给我买这么贵的东西，我姐说他买的。
[主播] 我现在能打开了。
[主播] 我看了很多朋友跟我讲的故事，有的讲自己
[主播] 生意失败了，感觉人生失无可失的故事。
[主播] 有的讲，比如说自己的父亲因为生了重病，几天先离开了他的故事。
[主播] 他感觉他的人生
[主播] 好像一个漂在大海上的船，他没有毛了。有的人跟我讲了他自己就在医院里身患癌症，然后在化疗。其实很多夸我的那种啊，董老师你真帅那种，那种话反而我不会过多去看，因为我知道我知道我想给大家传递的是一种力量感。也许有一天生活很明媚的时候，当你目及之处皆是春光与美好的时候，那会你可能就不需要我了。我总是一个苦大仇深的人，我总是一个心思细腻的人。但是你在人生难的时候，我觉得难得有人陪你，所以我特别希望刚才那句话能够今天温暖到你。今天我不爱世人，今天我只爱你。活著这本书，我在有一刻突然就特别体会到这个文章里头所讲的那种，那种活著的勇气是什么？就是我之前给大家讲过，我我是在陕西生长的。我在那里长大，虽然是很穷苦的农村生活。但至少家人给了我很好的教育和这个价值观的引导，他们从小鼓励我去感受自然，感受人的喜怒哀乐去读书。所以到现在虽然我人生也受了很多苦，但是我至少能够清楚的表达自己的想法，我觉得很多人可能就是觉得我能把事情说清楚而已，除此之外我也没有什么优点。我小时候其实也抱怨过我家里，坦诚来说，我也抱怨过我家里，然后直到这个去年，就我跟你说去年五一我开车不是带著我爸妈回了一趟湖北老家吗？那个老家就是我爷爷小时候他从那过来，其实他也没有在那生活过。在去的路上可能才聊得很细致。因为一路要穿过很多的大山，很高的悬崖，因为高速都是在那个悬崖之间绕来绕去。我爸说以前走就是走下面那个河滩，经常下了大，大雨的时候，然后那个水突然就涨起来了。说我这个我爷爷的这个爸爸和妈妈当年就是挑个蛋包爷爷从湖北一直挑挑著蛋走到了陕西老家。然后说走著走著突然上游的大水冲下来的，把蛋冲走了，两个老人就冲到河里头去把孩子抱出来，然后蛋就被水冲走了。他们一共走了几个，你想像大山深处连吃的都没有，那会孩子还在吃奶啊。你想他们晚上睡在哪里？我们甚至看到悬崖上有人把那个就当地有那些人把那个棺材吊上去，塞到悬崖里那种，你见过那种吧？然后呢，你想以前那个自然环境比较好的时候，大家可能在大山深处甚至会见到野兽，对吗？会见到狼。我就一路慢慢的开著，我就听著我爸在后坐在后排，然后就有一句没一句的跟我讲著。我那一路感觉是一个寻根之旅，我更觉得那是我一个精神得到洗涤的一个过程。我我很开心他跟我讲那些。我我爷爷那一代人老家在运西，在处于实验室。我我那一路的思绪就久久无法平静，我始终在想，我在想当时面对那样的苦难，他们是怎么坚持下来的呀？我在想对吧？我人生说多少难啊？不就是小时候家里穷点吗？上学整天被人看不起，挨打被欺负吗？喜欢的女孩子把我拒绝了好几次吗？对吧？董宇辉挺好，所以咱俩做兄弟。不就是自己在工作的时候好多年，对吧？很累吗？不就是身体点差，睡眠点差吗？不就是自己去年想不通，绕著北四环一圈一圈的转，回去写很多非主流的作文吗？我可以表达。我也可以诉苦。那是我的权利，因为我诉苦完之后我内心舒服一点。但是最终还是要找到继续生活的勇气。你知道去年五一那趟的旅行真的太有意义了。其实我当时是有个幻想的破灭，因为我爸描述的老家其实是一个好像是一个名门望族，但其实你做发现都是特别普通的小乡村。然后他所描述的那个传了好多代人那个牛皮纸的族谱在几十年前那场特殊的历史事件中被焚毁了。其实没有那么多的感觉，但是我那一路走回去，却听他讲著，因为我真的看过了一路过来的自然的，那种天险。我才感受到了那一代人活下去的勇气。于是我就理解了很多，所以我们时常要去感受这些，感受这些的目的并不是让你痛苦，而是让你重新有勇气，有乐观，有智慧。抱怨谁不会啊？能憋住不抱怨才牛呢。放弃多容易啊？能坚持熬下去才牛呢。我们很多时候小时候在瞻仰英雄，长大之后呢，你其实也可以理解成为你自己可以成为英雄的。我没有记错的话，孩子应该还有一首诗，叫做你要什么什么什么，然后默不作声穿越整座城市。对不起，我忘了，就是默不作声穿越整座城市那个，你可以搜一下。我我当时读完那那那一段之后，就突然就有了很多的勇气。我觉得那一段的勇气就瞬间让人豁然开朗了。导演你帮我搜一下那段，对不起啊，我我忘了那一段了，我忘了那一段可能给大家体验不好啊。那段应该就是说你要默不作声穿越整座城市，大概是那么说的。嗯，因为我知道这一两年大家可能受苦受得多吗？嗯。所以，在人生难的时候，试著从世间万物中寻找勇气。可以是这本书，可以是与好朋友的一次聊天。可以是去大江大河里头去感受自然，感受生命的力量。也可以是回到老家里，从明鸟叫里好好的睡一觉。吃饱饭，可以。可以是任何东西。如果是这本书的话，你可以去看，如果不是这本书，你去其他地方寻找你的精神动力。抱怨多容易啊？诉苦是弱者的权利。我记得好多年前我在抱怨工作难做的时候，当时宋老师跟我说，这个俊马面前无沟壑，怂人面前全是坎。当然这句话包说清醒了好几天。导演你刚才收到那句话了吗？
[嘉宾] 知道了。
[主播] 他怎么说的？
[嘉宾] 答应我，忍住你的痛苦。
[嘉宾] 不发一言。
[主播] 是
[嘉宾] 是孩子。
[主播] 是孩子是吧？
[主播] 答应我，忍住你的痛苦，不发一言，穿过这整座城市。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 就很给人力量感，你知道很多文字的优点在哪里，就是
[主播] 它不喧哗，不造作，但是它很给人力量感，答应我。
[主播] 什么？不发一言。
[嘉宾] 忍住痛苦。
[嘉宾] 不发一言。
[嘉宾] 穿过这整座城市。
[主播] 穿过这整座城市，对，我我记错了，不好意思啊。
[主播] 记忆力下降。
[主播] 对，当时宋老师跟我这样说的，叫俊马面前无沟壑。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 哎，沟壑怎么写，是这样写对吧？
[主播] 沟壑，不好意思啊。
[主播] 俊马面前无沟壑，是吗？
[嘉宾] 是。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 怂什么叫怂呢？
[主播] 怂就是follow,跟随你的内心。
[主播] 什么叫follow your heart?
[主播] 放弃是人性。
[主播] 认怂是人性。
[主播] 哭是人性。
[主播] 绝望是人性。
[主播] 但人为什么在修炼？
[主播] 人的修炼就是在自己的身上克服人性的缺点，在自己的身上克服这个时代。
[主播] 如果你总是第一时间顺从自己的内心，那就是认怂。
[主播] 怂就是尊从自己的心呢。
[主播] 与自己抗争。
[主播] 跟自己修炼。
[主播] 说怂人面前全是卡尔。
[主播] 他可能现在自己都不记得了。
[主播] 好多年前我听他说这句话。
[主播] 这是新东方转型的直播间。
[主播] 东方甄选。
[主播] 我叫董宇辉，我是一个教了八年的高中英语老师。
[主播] 我今天心情很好。
[主播] 今天心好的主要原因是因为我今天收到了很多我的学生给我的反馈。
[主播] 他们很开心。
[主播] 他说老师我英语考得很好。
[主播] 或者有孩子说老师我考得不怎么样好。
[主播] 但我不纠结了。
[主播] 我人生无憾了。
[主播] 我高中努力过。
[主播] 我特别害怕他们把胜负看得特别重，我害怕他们把结果看得特别重。
[主播] 以至于患得患失啊。
[主播] 所以我其实认识他们几年，我一直在给他们说结果不重要。
[主播] 内心无愧才重要。
[主播] 就像你中间离开这个城市，离开这个世界，你重要的只是你怎么样过好这一生。
[主播] 有孩子跟我说老师可能我没有期待中那么好。
[主播] 但是我内心无憾了。
[主播] 就像老师经常所说的，得到的是得到的叫青春。
[主播] 错过的叫人生。
[主播] 不一定总非得得偿所愿。
[主播] 人生有时候的美好就在于阴差阳错。
[主播] 阴差阳错的才能去那些城市，才能见那些人啊。
[主播] 阴差阳错的才能展开一段奇旅。
[主播] 阴差阳错的后来你才能去新东方当一个老师。
[主播] 阴差阳错的当了一个老师之后，你才教了50万的学生。
[主播] 阴差阳错的你后来才能站在屏幕前卖菜，给别人露露大脸，能讲你的故事。
[主播] 对不起，我这次讲活著吧。
[主播] 活著讲成了这样子。
[主播] 但是，我相信每个人也从我这里文字里能够感受到我想传递的力量。
[主播] 导演，这样讲有卖出去吗？
[嘉宾] 卖出去了，4000多万。
[主播] 啊，卖得不好是吧？
[嘉宾] 还行，挺好。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 行，还是得写小作文。
[主播] 咱今天晚上卖橄榄油是吧？
[主播] 西班牙的橄榄油是吗？
[嘉宾] 可以。
[主播] 安达卢西亚那个地方是吧？
[主播] 好。
[主播] 来，把油给我。
[主播] Extra virgin olive oil,特级初榨橄榄油的意思就是
[主播] 橄榄果摘下来24小时之内就炸了。
[主播] 鲜，所以口感好。
[主播] 国外进的油，回来灌装。
[主播] 酸度很重要。
[主播] 好的油，酸度就比较低。
[主播] 当然自然炸出来的酸度低，有的人他是通过后期的这个化学手段故意把酸度降低，那不算。
[主播] 国标是小于等于0.8%,我们的酸度是小于等于0.6%,口感风味营养得到很大的保存。
[主播] 原产国是西班牙。
[主播] 我好多年前去过西班牙。
[主播] 想到了，我准备写小作文了啊。
[主播] 大家想录的朋友可以准备好。
[主播] 看看现在几点。
[主播] 8点55。
[主播] 我们要不要等个9点？
[主播] 想到西班牙，我首先想到的是马德里的艺术馆。
[主播] 我在里头看到过达利的作品。
[主播] 我想到的是那些穿越的历史。
[主播] 仍然停留的宫殿。
[主播] 我想到巴塞罗那，我想到地中海的海岸，想到了
[主播] 灌在杯子里的三个利亚。
[主播] 和端到你面前的海鲜饭。
[主播] 我想到安达卢西亚，他是西班牙最南部，也是欧洲最南部的一个城市。
[主播] 他与直布罗陀海峡呢，紧邻著。
[主播] 所以直布罗陀海峡将欧洲与非洲切断。
[主播] 直布罗陀海峡很宽啊。
[主播] 虽然我们无法跨越天险，虽然我们无法跨越天险。
[主播] 但我还是想牵你的手。
[主播] 把景色尽览。
[主播] 哎，压上来。
[嘉宾] 是的，单压。
[主播] 嗯，差不多。
[主播] 我刚才重来一遍，我刚说啥？
[主播] 当我想到西班牙，我想到的是
[主播] 不好意思，变重说第二遍，编不住了。
[主播] 当我想到西班牙，我想到的是马德里的艺术馆。
[主播] 我想到达利的话作和穿越时光的宫殿。
[主播] 我想到巴塞罗那。
[主播] 想到了
[嘉宾] 海鲜饭。
[主播] 阳光洒落的地中海岸。
[主播] 我想到承满杯子的三个利亚。
[主播] 以及端到你面前的海鲜饭。
[主播] 我想到安达卢西亚。
[主播] 那是欧洲的最南端。
[主播] 直布罗陀海峡将欧洲与非洲隔断。
[主播] 我生为凡人，虽无法带你跨越天险，但我仍愿牵你的手。
[主播] 将景色变览。
[主播] 大概是这个样子。
[嘉宾] 加会员会有优惠。
[主播] 点击屏幕中间，加入东方甄选的抖音会员店。
[主播] 里头有
[主播] 券，可以用券去买啊。
[嘉宾] 我们的自营品是大家用券去购买的。
[主播] 安达卢西亚为什么这个地方很牛呢？因为它是就是西班牙的南嘛。
[主播] 它它隔著海，隔著海岸对面就已经是非洲了。
[主播] 所以它跟那个海岸，那个海峡就是直布罗陀海峡。
[主播] 因为是直布罗陀海峡，所以
[主播] 仍然它其实是一种地中海气候。
[主播] 地中海气候的特点是啊，就是冬天呢，温度偏暖。
[主播] 夏天其实会有这个降水，对吧？
[主播] 但是冬天的温度很很热。
[主播] 如果你去过这个巴塞罗那，你就能明显的感觉到那种。
[主播] 世界上有三个非常经典的橄榄油产地，第一个当然是希腊。
[主播] 希腊，希腊半岛。
[主播] 第二个是意大利的亚平宁半岛。
[主播] 第三个是西班牙的伊比利亚半岛，伊比利亚半岛其实就是大家知道西班牙卖那个那个黑猪的火腿，对吧？
[主播] 西班牙火腿就是伊比利亚半岛的黑猪。
[主播] 吃吃了足够多的酱，像果，吃够了足够多的像果，然后在山林间奔跑之后，它的腿就非常的好吃。
[主播] 对，地中海的气候也很浪漫。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 你害怕严寒。
[主播] 你也害怕酷暑。
[主播] 所以
[主播] 我们要去看一看地中海的沿岸。
[主播] 夏天不燥。
[主播] 冬天也不冷。
[嘉宾] 穿上漂亮的裙子。
[主播] 你可以从容的穿上漂亮的裙子。
[主播] 把景色看遍。
[主播] 有朋友问我去过，我我去过西班牙。
[主播] 我是在17年。
[主播] 17年还是18年，当时去的西班牙。
[主播] 去的马德里。
[主播] 马德里，我们去看过那个Reina Sofia什么什么那个艺术馆，那个是2017年全国一卷高考阅读题C篇里头写的那个。
[主播] 里头有很多达利的作品。
[主播] 达利是一个极其高产的这个艺术家。
[主播] 还去了那个Museum Prado,就是普拉多艺术馆。
[主播] 就是大家所说那个丰田不是一款车叫Prado,翻译成霸道。
[主播] 其实Prado指的是海边的这个大道。
[主播] 指的大马路的意思。
[主播] 还去了这个巴塞罗那。
[主播] 在地中海边。
[主播] 真的就是夕阳西下，然后呢阳光洒落在这个海边上，然后呢海水来回的去冲刷。
[主播] 然后我们就坐在那里喝了一杯那个三个雷亚。
[主播] 就是其实就是水果块，红酒还有这个气泡水混合在一起。
[主播] 然后吃那个海鲜饭。
[主播] 但其实那个海鲜饭看你个人，你不一定喜欢，因为那个米是半生的，而且很咸。
[主播] 喜欢的朋友自己去拍啊。
[嘉宾] 我们有一个有的视频要给大家放。
[主播] 可以，可以给大家放一下，给大家看一下啊。
[主播] 有个人说董宇辉不要硬编，得编。
[主播] 编了之后你生活中的很多小的原本朴素的东西才有了特殊的美感。
[主播] 要不然生活太无趣了。
[主播] 睡觉，吃饭。
[主播] 重复的劳动。
[主播] 缺乏美感。
[主播] 为了让生活浪漫一些。
[主播] 我们要赋予原本很多平凡的事情，给它更多的意义才行。
[主播] 得变，必须会变。
[主播] 会变才有感觉呢。
[主播] 巴塞罗那是诺坎普啊。
[主播] 那个球馆，我还是在那个球馆门口拍了个照，但是我确实不懂，我也确实不会。
[主播] 想的朋友自己去拍啊。
[主播] 橄榄是一个特别，橄榄油是一个特别精致的这个食用油。
[主播] 它不适合这个高温去炒，因为它高温的话会有很大的烟，而且它里头的这个Omega的家族还有不饱和脂肪酸的这些营养就会被破坏了。
[主播] 所以其实特别好的就是什么？就是早餐，比如说你经常拌一些沙拉，或者你煮汤完了之后其实放它。
[主播] 也因为地中海沿岸特别特殊的气候，所以地中海沿岸的这个橄榄啊，或者是葡萄啊，其实它都有特别好的这个品质啊。
[主播] 也因为地中海沿岸特别特殊的气候，所以地中海沿岸的这个橄榄呀，或者是葡萄呀，其实它都有特别好的这个品质啊。
[主播] 朋友说想听我会继续编是吧？
[主播] 还想听我继续编的
[主播] 恢复一。
[主播] 我编完中你们下单了没？
[主播] 买点啊，别空手走，橄榄油是个好东西。
[主播] 就夏天你半菜的时候可以用它。
[主播] 或者你用空气炸锅去做东西，你可以上面撒橄榄油。
[主播] 还有大家喜欢这个健康食物，用这个沙拉里头其实可以用它。
[主播] 还想听作是吧？
[主播] 橄榄油的英语叫Olive oil。
[主播] Olive。
[主播] Oil叫油嘛，对吧？
[主播] 橄榄叫Olive,所以连起来叫Olive
[主播] Oil。
[主播] 特级出战。
[主播] 特殊的额外的叫extra。
[主播] Virgin,这个V
[主播] 写算了。
[主播] Virgin大家知道，第一个它可以形容只少女，对吧？
[主播] 第二个它也指比如说冬天下的第一场雪，可以叫Virgin snow。
[主播] Virgin snow。
[主播] 你像炸的第一遍的油叫Virgin,对吧？
[主播] 所以所以是extra Virgin Olive Olive oil, Olive,OK?
[主播] 继续编。
[主播] 我记得我们以前在高中学地理的时候，大家对于这个地中海气候就印象深刻。我其实没有感受。我从来没有去过那片土地看过。所以我把它的景色也给你描不清楚。直到我后来那年我们过年，大概就是在冬天的时候，真的去了一趟。从瓦伦西亚开始，我发现温度就越来越高了。呃，因为瓦伦西亚的晚上做的路边就已经不怎么冷了，而且冬天路边还有这个橘子和柠檬在树上呢。冬天啊，然后从瓦伦西亚第二天到了这个巴塞罗那之后，你感觉到越来越舒服了，就已经感觉不到太冷了。晚上坐在路边，然后举那个他们有的巨大的天气的炉子烧著，然后拿那个小的油条去沾那个巧克力酱吃。然后喝那个桑格利亚的酒，还有那个伊比利亚半岛黑猪的火腿片。很精致。
[主播] 你说你喜欢冬天。
[主播] 你喜欢大片的雪花，簌簌的落在山岭之间。
[主播] 所以我想到了遥远的北欧。
[主播] 我想到了
[主播] 我想到了挪威狭长的海湾以及极其宁静的瑞典。
[主播] 你说你喜欢夏天。
[主播] 你喜欢看万物自由生长。
[主播] 充满力量的美感。
[主播] 我想到了非洲。
[主播] 我想到了那些潮湿的河谷。
[主播] 想到了那些平原。
[主播] 你突然又后悔了。
[主播] 你说你不喜欢夏天，因为你手心会出汗。
[主播] 你说你也不喜欢冬天。
[主播] 你还怕你手脚冰冷。
[主播] 你担心那样。
[主播] 就没有办法把手牵。
[主播] 所以啊，我懂你的意思。
[主播] 这次我们去欧洲的最难短。
[主播] 我们去西班牙。
[主播] 我们去感受没有那么寒冷的冬天。
[主播] 我们可以漫步在海边。
[主播] 我们可以永东万真选这一瓶橄榄油，做一次精致的早餐。
[主播] 都行，你快乐就好。
[主播] 这次编的意境怎么样？
[嘉宾] 不错是吧？
[主播] 我喜欢大片雪花，簌簌落下那种森林间，于是想到了挪威狭长的海湾和宁静的瑞典。
[主播] 北欧几国嘛，对吧？
[主播] 你说你喜欢夏天，喜欢万物自由生长的画面。
[主播] 想到了非洲潮湿的河谷。
[主播] 和广袤的平原。
[主播] 没有问题吧？
[主播] 动员里头的动物在奔跑。
[主播] 你又担心冬天太冷。
[主播] 温度太低，你手脚冰冷，夏天太热，你手心出汗。
[主播] 很真实吧？
[主播] 没办法把手牵。
[主播] 所以呀，我都懂你，这次我们去欧洲的最难短。
[主播] 与非洲隔海相望。
[主播] 地中海气候，那里冬天并不严寒。
[主播] 你我可以并手并肩走在走在海边。
[主播] 可以永东真选这一瓶初级特炸橄榄油。
[主播] 做一次精致的早餐，你看，每一句都能压著运。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 还可以，还可以。
[主播] 还可以，现在不太矫情吧？
[嘉宾] 不矫情说。
[主播] 我以前高中写这种文章就经常被我老师批评。
[主播] 觉得我写的太矫情。
[嘉宾] 句句不谈爱，句句充满了对爱的向往。
[主播] 你想像啊，就是睡醒的清晨。
[主播] 拿这瓶东安真选的初期特级出炸橄榄油。
[主播] 弄一个沙拉，对吧？
[主播] 煮的鸡蛋，还有那个牛油果，对吗？
[主播] 这个，还有那个叫什么？
[主播] 我们，李麦，right?
[主播] OK,还有其他的蔬菜。
[主播] That's it.
[主播] Yeah。
[主播] 多有美感啊。
[主播] 多有美感。
[主播] 你看只要睡好了，功力就回来了。
[主播] 小作文也能编了。
[主播] 睡眠差什么都不行。
[主播] 所以身体才是最重要的。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 小作文写得好，最后就是没有身体去享受。
[主播] 来各位朋友们。
[主播] 初级特级出炸橄榄油啊，各位朋友们，就是橄榄油也是一个
[主播] 非常大的品类。
[主播] 如果说从国外直接进口的油，而且是特级出炸的，而且它的酸度小于我们已经小于等于0.6%的时候。
[主播] 经典产地的橄榄油。
[主播] 你可以去与其他品牌进行对比啊，大家不能张嘴就说，你们这也太贵了。
[主播] 否定了我所有的努力。
[主播] 啊，是这个高DHA的鸡蛋。
[主播] 这个鸡蛋前两天我们都不敢讲，每次往这放迅速就流空了。
[嘉宾] 每天的话就七八百单。
[主播] 每天只有七八百单，是吧？
[嘉宾] 今天还有600单。
[主播] 朋友说等会不行吗？都带货榜第二了。
[主播] 不要在意那样。
[主播] 不要在意那些。
[主播] 在意那些你开始痛苦了。
[主播] 何必呢？
[主播] 高DHA的鸡蛋一共只有800单。
[主播] 每天下单都是第二天早上新鲜的鸡蛋才给你发。
[主播] 整个完整的盒子。
[主播] 为什么叫高DHA的鸡蛋呢？
[主播] 因为一个鸡蛋中它的DHA含量不少于，刚才说160毫克。
[主播] 所以正常情况下两个鸡蛋就可以满足一个成年人一天的DHA的需求了。
[主播] DHA是什么？
[主播] 是Omega3。
[主播] Omega3的家族在人体的一些部位是一些重要组成部分。
[主播] 这是一个事实。
[主播] Like for your eyeballs and your brain, okay?
[主播] Essential component,重要组成部分。
[嘉宾] 鸡蛋太光了。
[主播] 太光了。
[嘉宾] 真的。
[主播] 那咱还有其他的鸡蛋吗？
[主播] 你让我把essential component写完，可以吗？
[嘉宾] 可以，你写完。
[主播] 好，谢谢。
[嘉宾] 看一下其他的。
[主播] Essential。
[主播] Essence叫做精华，对吧？
[主播] 核心的东西。
[主播] 所以它essential。
[主播] Essential。
[主播] 这个单词大家可能不太不太学过，组成物。
[主播] 我给你换一个词。
[主播] Essential component。
[主播] No, like ingredient,你学过吗？
[主播] Ingredient。
[主播] Ingredient是配料，它不对。
[主播] Essential content你总学过吧？
[主播] Content就是内容。
[主播] 内容或者内涵。
[主播] 就里头所含有的东西嘛，对吧？
[主播] 比如说你拿了一个瓶子里头所装的水就是里头的content,可以吧？
[主播] 里头所含内容，比如你端了一个碗，里头所装的饭就是它的content。
[主播] OK?
[主播] 所以DHA是这个鸡蛋里头的一个essential content,重要的组成部分。
[主播] 可以吧？
[主播] Component这个词大家应该有的学生高三学生是知道的。
[主播] 我还把屏幕前。
[主播] 注意，高中以上的学生是知道，component,就叫重要组成部分，如果你没有见过这个词，无所谓啊，无所谓，它不重要。
[主播] Essential content也可以啊。
[主播] Essential component or essential content is decisive to your body。
[主播] 对你的身体还是很重要的。
[主播] 哈。
[主播] 用decisive有点过分了。
[主播] It's like important。
[主播] 它比较重要。
[主播] And beneficial。
[主播] 它是有好处的。
[主播] It's kind of, yeah。
[主播] Beneficial。
[主播] Beneficial, okay?
[主播] It's important and beneficial to your physical health, to your body, to your stature。
[主播] To your wisdom。
[主播] To your
[主播] Growth, okay?
[主播] 东方真选的高DHA鸡蛋每天只有800单。
[主播] 拍到的恭喜你，拍不到的就算了。
[主播] 接下来给大家推荐的是啥？是这个吗？导演，我看你放的这个。
[主播] 不是吧？
[主播] 不是啊，好好好，来下一个。
[主播] 我又把它拿上来了。
[嘉宾] 上个硬货。
[主播] 这硬货，这真的动的还帮硬啊。
[主播] 整个半只羊。
[主播] 你再说这贵，我生气了啊。
[主播] 半只羊多少钱？
[主播] 300多，我记得是。
[嘉宾] 而且是滩羊。
[主播] 滩羊，宁夏滩羊，半只300多。
[主播] 你去宁夏当地买。
[主播] 我冬天，每年冬天我都给爷爷买，爷爷奶奶买一只宁夏滩羊。
[主播] 然后因为我以前有同事，他现在在银川生活。
[主播] 我当时就让他联系他们当地养羊的人。
[主播] 一只买下来可能得1300左右，加上运费都2000左右了。
[主播] 我每年都买。
[主播] 因为空运过来运费确实贵。
[主播] 当然大家不用害怕，你收到的不是这么大的一个半只羊，你收到的是他已经给你去开了的。
[主播] 这头就是整个半只。
[主播] 导演这半只解开了都有哪些，你让我看一下那个规格。
[主播] 对。
[主播] 得给大家说清楚这个的规格都有什么啊。
[主播] 羊前腿两斤，羊后腿两斤，羊蝎子两斤，羊排两斤，羊小腿两斤，还有
[主播] 还有那些炖肉的料。
[主播] 所以肉一共是十斤。
[主播] 因为羊它不可能长特别大嘛。
[主播] 肉一共十斤，368,算下一斤36。
[主播] 算很便宜的羊肉了。
[主播] 啊，那个鸡蛋对。
[主播] 有朋友提醒说鸡蛋如果收到的时候。
[主播] 这个你需要放在冰箱里，然后需要冷冻啊，冷冻大概在15天以内，就是一个长鲜期，这时候15天以内吃完口感是比较好的。
[主播] 如果你放的时间长的话，可能口感就不怎么好了。
[主播] 有朋友说让牵上一只羊。
[主播] 牵一只完整的羊可能没有办法给你送啊。
[主播] 它是已经动好，然后去成块了啊。
[主播] 整个是十斤。
[主播] 大家发现董宇辉这个对产品规格记不熟。
[主播] 收到了，收到了，我会努力的啊。
[嘉宾] 主要是给大家一整羊。
[主播] 一只整羊可能不是自己的了。
[主播] 一只整羊没法养。
[主播] 编小作文呢，产品规格确实我还需要进步。
[主播] 来来，导演，你把这个拿下去，要不然镜头前有点吓人。
[主播] Yeah,谢谢。
[主播] 让让男孩子呢，让男孩子呢，对对对。
[主播] 对，下次这种活你来啊，不要让女孩子呢。
[主播] 来，我们继续给大家推荐，还有什么农产品今天晚上？
[嘉宾] 还有我们的乌骨鸡。
[主播] 乌骨鸡还是乌骨鸡？
[嘉宾] 乌骨鸡。
[主播] 乌鸡嘛，是吧？
[嘉宾] 是的。
[主播] 乌鸡炖汤特别方便。
[主播] 而且它是特别容易出汤的，出汤色的，稍微一顿就是白色的汤。
[主播] 乌鸡。
[主播] 这个是菌菇包，两个一块用的，是吧？
[主播] 菌菇包是搭配著买的还是说送的？
[嘉宾] 是送的。
[主播] 两只鸡送。
[主播] 这个乌鸡还挺大的，坦诚来说。
[主播] 因为通常来说大家买乌鸡一般都是炖汤的，所以很多人乌鸡其实不用养特别大，因为很少人去专门说吃乌鸡的肉。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 两只乌鸡，然后送这一包这个金汤包啊。
[主播] 想要的盆自己去拍。
[主播] 乌鸡。
[主播] 有朋友说问这个送不送锅呀？
[嘉宾] 这个不送。
[主播] 不送锅啊，不送锅。
[嘉宾] 对锅现在比较敏感。
[主播] 对。
[主播] 怕背锅是吧？
[主播] 哈哈。
[主播] 那个羊是切开的，不是给你送整个半个。
[主播] 整个半个没有办法送过去，因为那个太大了，可能不太好装箱。
[主播] 它会给你切成块，然后放到里头啊。
[主播] 然后呢，比如说咱之前牛排的那个锅，其实是先发牛排，随后发锅，是吧？
[嘉宾] 是分开的。
[主播] 是分开发的，可以的啊。
[嘉宾] 不能最完美，买一个锅了。
[主播] 乌鸡，想要的盆自己去拍啊。
[主播] 这个乌鸡是可以炖汤用的，嗯。
[嘉宾] 咱这个是新鲜的，新鲜的，所以每天的话量也不是很大。
[主播] 新鲜的，每天有多少只？
[嘉宾] 8000只。
[主播] 乌鸡炖汤的时候，家里有沙锅，然后呢，把它放进去，然后放上一些最基本的料就行了。
[主播] 然后再把这个君子放进去。
[主播] 其实只要是好的材料，怎么做都好吃。
[主播] 稍微煮一下，然后那个汤的颜色就就很白了。
[主播] 然后煮出来的汤也很香。
[主播] 我之前还有一次在前年吧，我忘了是前年还是大前年，有一次好像是
[主播] 妈妈的生日还是母亲节，我忘了具体是什么什么日子了。
[主播] 我从西安还专门赶回去了一趟潼关的老家，然后给妈妈煮了一次这个乌鸡汤。
[主播] 妈妈嘴上说这个不要太麻烦，以后不要回来。
[主播] 这种事情发不来，这趟一趟花多少时间？
[主播] 但是他很开心。
[主播] 想买的朋友自己去拍啊。
[主播] 有朋友说怎么了？
[主播] 羊肉肥不肥？咱刚那个羊肉肥不肥？
[嘉宾] 不肥。
[主播] 是小羊是吧？
[嘉宾] 对，是小高羊。
[嘉宾] 要不给他还有吗？
[嘉宾] 咱再开一去。
[主播] 可以给大家展示。
[主播] 你你拿那个袋子就行，不要把整个羊搬过来，OK?
[主播] 对。
[主播] 不要让他搬整个羊，因为它太重了，它拿不动。
[主播] 我们这个直播间里没有太大的冷库，要它放动的外面去。
[嘉宾] 小高羊它的肉，脂肪分布很均匀。
[主播] 小羊一般不会特别肥，特别肥特别厚的羊一般是老羊。
[主播] 如果家里养过羊的或者自己买过肉，你就知道了啊。
[主播] 羊特别大了，身上可能会有很厚的脂肪层，这是第一个。
[主播] 第二个可能羊大了就会比较山。
[主播] 第三个可能就是肉会相对偏老一些，所以大家现在喜欢的大部分吃的都是半年左右的叫高羊。
[主播] 到一年左右的羊其实开始变老了，一年以上的羊就非常老了。
[嘉宾] 非常大。
[主播] 可以拆一个是吧？
[主播] 这个里头的包装只能保一些。
[主播] 羊排。
[主播] 把它清洗完之后放在锅里可以炖一下。
[主播] 然后呢，放在沙锅里咕嘟嘟嘟的冒著热气。
[主播] 然后再把其他的配料放进去。
[主播] 等到他回家的时候，哇，厨房里飘著全部都是香气。
[主播] 饭好了，快来吃饭。
[主播] 大概就是那种生活的气息，嗯。
[主播] 我们之前给大家讲过为什么宁夏的滩羊好呢？
[主播] 因为宁夏它属于核套平原的这个西套。
[主播] 因为黄河水在这流得慢，所以盐减地，盐减地。
[主播] 因此呢，这个生长的植物里头它的酸减，这个减度比较高。
[主播] 然后羊吃完之后酸减中和了。
[主播] 酸减一中和，肉就不怎么山。
[主播] 当肉不山的时候，大家就特别喜欢，因为羊肉不山很难得呀，对不对？
[主播] 喜欢的朋友自己去拍啊。
[主播] 羊肉你在最开始拿的时候，你摸完手上是有一点点这个味道，这个属于正常的啊。
[主播] 这个是正常的，因为我我每年冬天都买。
[主播] 而且每次我清理完之后，我发现确实手上有味道，但它煮熟了之后就没有这个味道了，很香的。
[主播] 这个可以了，可以了，我觉得应该可以了吧？
[主播] 你你还要看吗？
[主播] 宁夏的太阳肉啊。
[主播] 有朋友说这个羊太可怜了，只能活半年。
[主播] 赫拉利在人类简史中就提到了。
[主播] 他说如果物种的成功，一个物种的成功仅仅以它的数量来论的话。
[主播] 因为数量越多，基因丰富性越强。
[主播] 如果仅以数量来论，那其实世界上特别成功的动物应该是鸡，猪，牛羊，应该是这些东西，因为它们的数量特别大，对吧？
[主播] 尤其是养鸡，那太多了。
[嘉宾] 羊的话有点过来。
[主播] 羊也供不过来了。
[主播] 每天有多少单？
[嘉宾] 咱们今天的话还有
[嘉宾] 1100单。
[主播] 只有1100单了，是吧？
[主播] 好。
[主播] 你要从这个生物这个丰富的基因性上去讲，它是成功的。
[主播] 但是你要从他们的生活体验上来讲，那确实很糟糕的。
[主播] 就是赫拉利在人类简史中也提到了这一段。
[主播] 来，这个乌鸡想朋友自己去拍啊。
[主播] 有没有？
[主播] 有朋友问有没有牛肉今天？
[嘉宾] 今天没有牛肉。
[主播] 没有牛肉啊。
[主播] 下一个是，什么？
[主播] 特伦苏牛奶是吧？
[主播] 来来来。
[主播] 两箱牛奶，纯牛奶，然后呢，一箱酸奶。
[主播] 我们在喝牛奶的时候，其实就是为了补充其中的盖或者蛋白质。
[主播] 然后所以大家可以看一下，这个一箱是12盒，两箱就是24盒。
[主播] 然后这个酸奶呢，就是10盒，所以加起来是34盒。
[主播] 34盒100多，算下一盒是三块。
[主播] 我记得是三块四毛五好像是。
[嘉宾] 对，三块四毛五。
[主播] 对于这个特伦苏来说，它的价格还是非常便宜的啊。
[主播] 特伦苏这三个字从哪来的？是这个单词叫做
[主播] 就指优质的特别好的。
[主播] 你会发现有的比如说歌手他出的专辑，他就给你来个就是精装版。
[主播] 通常就这么说。
[主播] 特伦苏应该大部分省份都能分，都能送的。
[主播] 我看有朋友说这个不能发。
[主播] 大部分应该是可以发的啊。
[嘉宾] 对应过好汤。
[嘉宾] 给爱的人。
[主播] 如果是广东人的话，他应该能懂这种浪漫，嗯。
[主播] 喝汤是一个，我觉得吃完饭很有意思的。
[主播] 给爱的人
[主播] 如果是广东人的话，他应该能懂这种浪漫。
[主播] 喝汤是一个我觉得吃完饭很有仪式感的事情，我不知道为什么，我我很喜欢喝汤。
[主播] 但是也坦诚给大家说，因为汤其实大部分的香味是脂肪的味道。
[主播] 如果 可能喝就是大部分的这个煮的汤，其实到最后你说营养，营养主要还是吃肉的蛋白质嘛，对吧？但是喝起来确实很有味道，因为有些氨基酸的味道嘛，所以口感确实很香。
[主播] 喜欢喝的朋友自己去自己去拍啊。
[主播] 然后牛奶的话就是家里每天都要用。
[主播] 有些朋友在问保质期，保质期跟生产日期。
[主播] 呃，这个鲜奶呢，大概是5月15以后的日期。
[主播] 然后呢，这个酸奶的话，时间都是6月多了都。
[嘉宾] 6月1号。
[主播] 6月1号之后的，然后他们俩的保质期都是半年，都是六个月，所以请你不用担心它的保质期，因为你按照你一天家里如果两三口，一天两三罐奶的这个消耗量，其实很快就完了。
[主播] 它不是零七牛奶啊，我我知道你的担心，它不是零七牛奶。
[主播] 还有朋友说
[主播] 想要听其他的书是吧？
[主播] 我们加了给大家再讲更多的书啊。
[主播] 看来大家真的是喜欢学习了。
[主播] 真好。
[嘉宾] 可以。
[主播] 大家都喜欢学习，最喜欢看书了。
[主播] 啊？
[嘉宾] 把这个细节还是曾国藩。
[主播] 那两个都可以，把这个细节曾国藩都可以。
[主播] 我第一次在读到曾国藩的时候，有一个细节打动了我，就是
[主播] 曾国藩的正面与侧面。
[主播] 我第一次在读到曾国藩的时候，一个令我感动的一个细节是，大家以前都听过说为官必看曾国藩，对吧？为商必看胡雪岩。
[主播] 重臣啊。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 晚清重臣。
[主播] 官做的很大。
[主播] 有的人官做大了以后呢，
[主播] 可能就做不了一个普通人了。
[主播] 但是，我记得我以前在看曾国藩的时候，其中有一个细节说，他的孩子
[主播] 必须 这个要去自己 从事一些生活中最基本的劳动。
[主播] 他不接受自己的孩子对别人呼来喝去的，甚至出门不要做那种马车。甚至这个每天的这个端茶倒水也不要指示别人来做，自己去做。
[主播] 我很小很小的时候读到这个点。
[主播] 我当时觉得
[主播] 这不是很正常吗？
[主播] 但后来长大了，你见的人多了，
[主播] 你才发现能做到这一点很难。
[主播] 就是我们也不能说到事必躬亲，对吧？因为有的事情你确实不需要自己去做，没有必要，因为社会确实是有分工的。
[主播] 但是小的时候我读到那个点的时候，我突然就对这个人感觉到肃然起敬。
[主播] 而且越是在后来成长的过程中，你会发现，比如说很多时候在职场或者在社会里头，很多人他其实是容易受惯性思维的影响，他觉得你应该是去做这些事情。
[主播] 甚至 可能有的人做了做了一些比较高级的管理岗之后，发现自己基本已经没有生存能力了。
[主播] 什么事都是指唤别人来看。
[主播] 当年那一个特别小的点就让我对曾国藩这个人印象深刻。
[主播] 当然大家也可能听过曾国藩另一个故事，就是说他比较笨。
[主播] 被文章呢，背了一晚上。
[主播] 背了一晚上，结果没有背，没有记住，曾国藩身上的小偷都受不了，跳下来，说算了。
[主播] 你不用背了，我给你背，我都记住了。
[主播] 能能笨成那个样子。
[主播] 所以我当年在一开始学英语的时候，我背不过嘛，我妈有次气哭了，我妈说我儿子怎么这么笨。
[主播] 我当时就安慰他，我说妈你别哭，曾国藩当年也很笨，背了一晚上背不过，小偷都记住了。
[主播] 我觉得他不仅是一个重臣，他不仅取得了很大的这个成就，他不仅在现实中做了很多应该做的事情。
[主播] 他更重要的是，这个人他自身的修养和对自己的要求。
[主播] 我们以前说克己复礼，对吧？在自己的身上克服一个时代。
[主播] 很多话其实说起来容易，但是做起来很难。
[主播] 我特别建议屏幕前的爸爸妈妈们去读一读曾国藩。
[主播] 我觉得有时候读曾国藩并不一定非得是你要飞黄腾达，你要去学那些现实世界里聪明的技巧。
[主播] 更多时候就是学一个人朴实的为人处事之道。
[主播] 我我有理由相信一个愿意去读曾国藩的父母，也也大概有可能会能够成为一个身教言传的父母。
[主播] 因为我前几天给大家讲，我说这个，其实教育不是言传身教，你不用言传，不用言传，撒你，不用说。
[主播] 更多的去做就行了。
[主播] 呃，也有很多朋友说，他听到曾国藩的第一个故事也是这个屡战屡败，屡败屡战的故事。
[主播] 就是
[主播] 我们在他身上看到了很多人性的优点，所以我觉得这这本书
[主播] 也不只是一些人寻求个人成功的一套秘诀，它更应该的是成为屏幕以前每一个家长想要去给孩子去做好示范，做好生活中榜样的一本参考书目。
[主播] 曾国藩。
[主播] 我觉得不是说为官必看曾国藩。
[主播] 为父母为人，都应该去看看曾国藩。
[主播] 我们可以审视到这个人身上的优点。
[主播] 当然这套书还有一个好的地方就在于
[主播] 我之前说了，我说很多时候当我们带着有色眼镜去看一个人的时候，如果说他好，他浑身都是好，好到就算他的错也可以被原谅。
[主播] 我们在讨厌一个人的时候，他浑身都是错，错到不近人情。
[主播] 都不合理。
[主播] 所以这套书的好点叫曾国藩的正面与侧面，它能够换不同的角度去理解一个人。
[主播] 很理性的，很少有人能够去这样审视一个人。
[主播] 也很少有人能够从这样角度去审视一个时代。
[主播] 人是时代的产物。
[主播] 这套书特别好，然后我们给大家
[嘉宾] 只有3000单。
[主播] 只有3000单是吧？
[嘉宾] 法治的细节倒是很多。
[主播] 好，这套书大家想要需要自己去拍啊。
[主播] 我觉得
[主播] 都应该去看一看。我第一次读曾国藩是在大 大几，大一还是大二的寒假。
[主播] 大一寒假应该是，我后来都不，过年都不怎么回家了。
[主播] 我在大一的寒假当时就用我们宿舍所有社友的这个图书卡去图书馆借书。
[主播] 一个人只能借六本书好像是。
[主播] 我就用他们的全部借了很多书，最后用个拉杆箱拉回去的艺术，一箱子的书。
[主播] 那个寒假在这个农村老家的房间里头，真的是冰天雪地啊。
[主播] 手都冷。
[主播] 坐在家里整天看书。
[主播] 或者在院子里晒着太阳看书，看张爱玲，看张恨水，看胡雪岩，看曾国藩。
[主播] 我看到曾国藩身上很多品质的时候，当时正好处于那个冰天雪地的农村的院子里。
[主播] 我觉得那个环境也很适合，正好应景。
[主播] 好像也磨练我很多品质。
[主播] 好像也纠正了我很多人性上的弱点。
[主播] 所以这就是为什么我觉得曾国藩这套书值得屏幕前的每个人去看。
[主播] 文正啊。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 文正是
[主播] 去大家去综合理解曾曾国藩两字，文正，对吧？现在很多给孩子起名字，比如说我，我姓董，我给他叫董文正。
[主播] 其实文正两个字就是曾国藩的啊。
[主播] 除了曾国藩以外，我们今天还给大家找到了特别好的这个罗翔老师的书。
[主播] 这个前几天是一直没有库存的，今天终于给大家找来了库存。
[嘉宾] 今天有两万本。
[主播] 法治的细节。
[主播] 我之前给大家提到过，我说一个社会的底线是是什么？
[主播] 肯定不是道德，因为道德没有办法去约束别人。
[主播] 你经常在看到社会上发生一些让人感觉到匪夷所思，令人气愤，甚至有时候令人难以理解的事情的时候，
[主播] 我们深知道德不是对人的约束，道德是对人的引导。
[主播] 法律才是对人的约束。
[主播] 法律经常在我们看来可能是离生活很远的，因为不如果你没有学法律，或者你从小没有大量的普法的话，可能你觉得它离得很远很远。
[主播] 很多时候人们并不知道怎么在现实生活中用法律去约束别人，或者是纠正自己。
[主播] 罗翔老师的神奇之处就在于，他可以把相对我们觉得原本枯燥的法律讲得如此的通透和深入浅出。
[主播] 所以法外狂徒张三嘛。
[主播] 大家都喜欢听他的故事。
[主播] 大家也喜欢在一个清醒的人身上看到一个时代的幸运。
[主播] 我昨天说了，一个时代的幸运是拥有这些清醒的人。
[主播] 一个时代的幸运应该是这些清醒的人去著书立作，把自己很多的观点传递给更多的人。
[主播] 我我有理由相信啊，我有理由相信。
[主播] 如果我们都去看这些书，我们也要求孩子去看这些书的话，增强他们在很多法治上的理解，
[主播] 我们会把社会变得更好的地方。
[主播] 如果大家都是受过良好教育的，如果大家都在自己身上克服人性很多的缺点，
[主播] 我们也有理由相信社会会变得越来越好。
[主播] 因为前段时间确实发生了一些很糟糕的事情。
[主播] 我从来都是一个因为自己内心有一些些的正义感，容易变得激情慷慨的人。
[主播] 但是，我读完这套书之后，我突然感觉到首先是修炼自己。
[主播] 当我能做好自己的时候，这个社会上就会多一个我们所意义的好，我们的这个角度所看到的这个好人。
[主播] 当我是一个老师的时候，我去影响我班里的几百个学生，他就有几百个我们所谓的好人。
[主播] 当我们把这样的书让更多的成千上万的人去看的时候，我们也有理由相信在这样书里头所讲的观点和推崇的法治的精神影响下，
[主播] 就会有成千上万的我们所期待的好人。
[主播] 当这个社会上只有一个我们理解的好人的时候，他会受尽苦难。
[主播] 他会日子过得很惨。
[主播] 当有千万个这样的人的时候，这就成了这个时代最大的庆幸了。
[主播] 所以这就是为什么我觉得大家应该去多看一看罗翔老师的书。
[主播] 这是第一个书写的好。
[主播] 第二个呢，罗翔老师这个人也特别值得人喜欢。
[主播] 大家经常能看到他的很多的，一些精彩的发言，对吧？
[主播] 人间清醒。
[主播] 一个如此对自己苛责，一个如此深度自行，一个如此充满着理性光辉的人，他也可以在网上被人骂到退网。
[主播] 有时候还挺难理解的。
[主播] 一个时代它是需要包容的，一个时代是需要公正的，一个时代是需要去理性而全面的去看待人和事的。
[主播] 这头包括有道德对我们的约束，这头当然也包括法治对我们的约束。
[主播] 我觉得罗翔老师牛牛在，他可以把两个进行非常高效的结合。
[主播] 他不仅知道从法律的角度，每个人和一个社会应该怎么去做。
[主播] 他更多时候其实是以道德的角度给自己提出了更高的要求来约束自己。
[主播] 每个人都需要清醒一些。
[主播] 强烈推荐这本书，法治的细节。
[主播] 他说艺术是自由的，但并非无拘无束。
[主播] 我特别害怕我们一代人变得脑袋空空，然后又极其容易被物质裹挟。
[主播] 我们变得没有立场，又极其容易被各种的舆论所引导。
[主播] 我们变得没有思考，又容易被各种意见领袖所裹挟。
[主播] 我特别害怕会变成那样子。
[主播] 因为我是一个老师，我清楚的知道，如果一代年轻人长大都是那样子的话，
[主播] 我们给他创造一个怎么样糟糕的世界。
[主播] 所以我经常在镜头前呼吁理性，我呼吁大家冷静，我呼吁大家全面，我呼吁大家周全的去看这些东西。
[主播] 我甚至之前给大家讲过，我说如果因为很多朋友特别喜欢我们。
[主播] 对吧？有的朋友比如说因为喜欢，所以对我有特别的偏爱。
[主播] 说董老师，我看见网上有人说你不好，我给你骂他了。
[主播] 其实我的第一反应是你骂他干啥，让他说。
[主播] 表达是每个人的观点。
[主播] 如果
[主播] 表达更是每个人的自由。
[主播] 每个人应该有自由的去表达自己的观点。
[主播] 当然我们说自由不等同于随意，对吧？
[主播] 那他说的言之物，他说错了。
[主播] 他说错了，我也没事，我挨句骂怎么了？
[主播] 但如果我们用同样糟糕的方式再进行语言攻击他，我跟他变得就一模一样了。
[主播] 是不是他骂了我，我就要反过去骂他？
[主播] 我觉得有的时候良知是需要 良知是需要法律去维护的，但良知更多时候是需要去用道德去唤醒的。
[主播] 这就是为什么罗翔老师这套书，我读完之后很感动。
[主播] 然后读完之后你再去看一下他在各种社交媒体上的诸多的那些发言的经典的视频。
[主播] 我们总是看到了一个愁容满面的清醒的哲人，在镜头前诉说着自己对于一些荒谬的事情的观点。
[主播] 他极力的呼喊，虽然他并没有说这个特别高亢的声音。
[主播] 但是我觉得他在极力的呼喊，呼喊着人类的理性，呼喊着人类的文明。
[主播] 他呼吁着想让一个社会变得更好，因为互联网的出现，它首先非常方便的传递了很多的知识，坦诚来说。
[主播] 但是互联网的出现也让也让经常的舆论变成了一种可以被用来利用的工具。
[主播] 我们不能理性的去观察，我们也不能全面的去分析，我们更不能正确的去判断。
[主播] 那我们将来要去何处给自己的子孙留下一片精神家园？
[主播] 我是这么理解的。
[主播] 所以这套书我觉得你应该去看一看。
[主播] 罗翔老师的书，这个书呢，前几天我们找压根就没有库存，这两天才专门给大家找到了库存。
[嘉宾] 还有一万本。
[主播] 只剩一万本了。
[主播] 今晚一共上多少本？
[嘉宾] 上了两万本。
[主播] 上两万本。
[主播] 我我在卖货呢，我在卖货呢，朋友说让卖货，我在卖货呢，我卖这本书呢。
[主播] 嗯 康德那句话非常经典，说这个世界上有两个事情，我越是长久的凝视，越是在内心感到他的崇高。
[主播] 第一个是头顶的星空，第二是内心的道德准则。
[主播] 但不是每个人都有如康德一般的自我修养和自我约束。
[主播] 所以更多时候
[主播] 我们是需要去了解法治。
[主播] 法是什么？
[主播] 法是一种约定俗成的社会契约。
[主播] 当我们都去读法，懂法，并且去守法的时候，
[主播] 我觉得这是一个社会开始文明，而且进步的一个重要标志。
[主播] 我们如果大家也都平常去愿意读这类书籍的时候，法律再也不是束之高阁，落满灰尘的文件。
[主播] 法律也不再是离你生活很遥远，用的时候才去基于诉苦的审判工具。
[主播] 法律应该更多的成为每一个人生活中对自己对自己的要求，以及你为人处事的一个参考。
[主播] 所以为什么要读这些书？
[主播] 我庆幸我读过这些书，我也庆幸我看过罗翔老师的很多的经典的系列视频。
[主播] 我们通过弘扬法治精神，创造一个文明的社会。
[主播] 我们通过创造一个文明的社会，唤醒更多人内心的良知。
[主播] 我们通过唤醒更多人内心的良知，给子孙留下一个理想中的世界。
[主播] 我特别害怕，如果有一天就是古人他在那个物质条件非常艰苦的情况下，他经常在思考自己的内心追求是什么，对吧？
[主播] 他们都在觉得要恢复周礼。
[主播] 他们都在提出心学。
[主播] 他们都在提出理学。
[主播] 他们都在提出那些东西。
[主播] 好像到了现在，人类的思考方式空前变得容易，知识获取也变得空前的方便的时候，我们我们却迷失了。
[主播] 我们迷失在了意见的裹挟，我们迷失在了各种荒谬的冲突中。
[主播] 我们既没有理性，我们时常也没有感情。
[主播] 我觉得挺可悲的，对不起，我这块我不能说的特别的直白和刺耳。
[主播] 但是
[主播] 我相信大家能从一个屏幕前老师
[嘉宾] 要不我们换一本吧，这本只有3000。
[主播] 只有3000了，不影响不影响，我说完吧。
[主播] 我相信大家能从一个老师这个欲言又止的表情和动作里头，感觉到我对很多事情的遗憾。
[主播] 他们是谁的父亲，又是谁的儿子？
[主播] 为什么会如此的泯灭良知？
[主播] 所以我时常看到那些如果说挺难受的，所以我更觉得每个人都应该去读读这种事了，这种书了。
[主播] 坦诚来说啊。
[主播] 许先生的书找到了吧？
[主播] 历史学家。
[主播] 万古江河。
[主播] 第一章是古代以前中国地区的考古略说，中华文化的黎明，公元前16世纪的公元前三世纪。
[主播] 公元前那孔子已经诞生了。
[主播] 中国的中国是公元三，公元前三世纪的公元二世纪。
[主播] 东亚的中国。
[主播] 亚洲多元体系的中国，进入世界体系的中国。
[主播] 进入世界体系中国的上篇下篇。
[主播] 老先生文化很深，但是讲东西很浅。
[主播] 我的意思深入浅出的钱。
[主播] 很幸运是我们在看他的书的时候，娓娓道来。
[主播] 思路清晰。
[主播] 能把历史讲明白的人，是聪明人。
[主播] 能把历史讲明白之后，还让你对他产生兴趣的人，是智慧的人。
[主播] 老先生就是智慧的人。
[主播] 这本书我其实没有读完，坦诚来说，我我必须坦诚的承认我没有读完。
[主播] 因为我最近几天还在继续看。
[主播] 我今天中午在这个拍这个我们这个其他的媒体频道的朋友们需要的视频之前，我还在继续看这本书。
[主播] 我还没有看完。
[主播] 但我觉得这套书我读完之后还是挺感兴趣的。
[主播] 我们知道了自己是如何走到了今天。
[主播] 我们也看到了在整个世界其他地方崛起或者衰落的时候，我们究竟有过哪些值得庆幸的机会，或者是错过的遗憾。
[主播] 很多朋友问我最近在看什么书，我最近就在看这本书。
[主播] 感兴趣你可以先看。
[主播] 看完了之后，我明天应该能看完吧。
[主播] 我明天看完了之后再给大家继续分享分享。
[主播] 我觉得我现在还没有彻底读懂。
[主播] 等我明天彻底读懂了，我再给大家分享。
[主播] 来，还有什么书今天？
[主播] 理想国三部曲。
[主播] 理想国今天有吗？
[主播] 我觉得我现在还没有彻底读懂。
[主播] 等我明天彻底读懂了，我再给大家分享。
[主播] 来，还有什么书我今天？
[主播] 理想国三部曲。
[主播] 理想国今天有吗？
[其他] 有。
[其他] 平板世界。
[主播] 平板世界有是吧？
[其他] 嗯。
[主播] 有朋友要农产品。
[主播] 农产品这个羊牌是吧，现在有？
[其他] 有。
[主播] 给大家上个羊牌啊。
[主播] 今天晚上那个橄榄油还有没导演？
[其他] 还有。
[其他] 还有的。
[主播] 橄榄油还有啊。
[主播] 想要橄榄油的朋友自己去拍啊。
[主播] 物火之重那本书没了，前两天库存特别少，只有几千本。
[主播] 我在那个我们还有个图书的号上，我提到那个迅速就空了。
[主播] 然后后来就再一直没有找到。
[主播] 东方甄选。
[主播] 给大家推出的特级初榨橄榄油。
[主播] 在前几年，世界上突然流行过一阵关于各个地方饮食文化的研究。
[主播] 地中海沿岸后来就被人们尤其的关注，因为那个地方人们吃的相对健康一些。
[主播] 确实健康一些。
[主播] 然后呢，后来就有一种饮食文化开始流行叫地中海饮食。
[主播] 地中海饮食里头一个特点啥？
[主播] 对于蔬菜不过度加工。
[主播] 减少油脂的摄入。
[主播] 但他们的油脂主要是橄榄油。
[主播] 因为橄榄油里头的不饱和脂肪酸和Omega家族相对丰富。
[主播] 所以对人体是有很多好处的。
[主播] 而且它里头所含的营养其实是在我们平常所吃的其他油里头找不到的。
[主播] 橄榄油可以怎么弄？大家平常比如说拌个沙拉。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 又因为橄榄油它橄榄所生长的环境比较好。
[主播] 因为大家都知道地中海沿岸嘛，地中海气候。
[主播] 冬季比较温暖，夏季呢相对会温度低一些。
[主播] 相比其他地方，它就没有那么的夏天燥或者冬天冷。
[主播] 因此特殊的企候赋予了橄榄特殊的品质。
[主播] 我刚刚讲橄榄的时候，
[主播] 给大家想到说，你说你喜欢冬天。
[主播] 所以我想到了你喜欢大片的雪花，簌簌的落在山岭之间。
[主播] 所以，
[主播] 所以我会想到遥远的北欧，我会想到挪威深纵深的海岸以及宁静的瑞典。
[主播] 你说你喜欢夏天，喜欢万物竞相生长的草原。
[主播] 所以我会想到非洲潮湿的河谷。
[主播] 我也会想到那些辽阔的平原。
[主播] 但是夏天太热，冬天太冷。
[主播] 所以，我决定牵你的手去欧洲的最南端，去西班牙的安达卢西亚。
[主播] 直布罗陀海峡隔开与非洲隔海相望。
[主播] 特殊的地理优势。
[主播] 温度适宜的自然条件。
[主播] 用东方甄选的橄榄油，开始精致的早餐。
[主播] 如果你是平常喜欢吃拌沙拉的那些，你可以拿这个油就直接拌沙拉用。
[主播] 它不是用一个大家平常高温去炒的那种啊。
[主播] 不是那样炒的。
[主播] 因为你这样去炒的话，可能会破坏它其中的营养，而且可能烟就比较大了。
[主播] 还想要什么书，今天晚上还有什么书吗？
[主播] 我看很多朋友说还想听书。
[主播] 但是晚上好像书确实比较少一些，是吧？
[主播] 除了这几个书以外还有什么？
[其他] 万历十五年。
[其他] 十五年。
[主播] 可以可以。
[主播] 大家要的万历十五年到了啊。
[主播] 万历十五年我第一次读的时候是16年去温哥华在那个飞机上。
[主播] 因为从北京起飞落到温哥华机场，一共飞了大概快10个小时吧，我记得。
[主播] 我一到晚上真的睡不着。
[主播] 因为时差不对。
[主播] 时间不对，有时差嘛。
[主播] 所以我在飞机上把那本书匆匆的翻了一遍。
[主播] 我再次读那本书是后来飞悉尼。
[主播] 因为我发现我一般在读历史的时候，内心很平静。
[主播] 我坐飞机时常紧张。
[其他] 对。
[主播] 有时候颠簸起来，我就会突然会紧张。
[主播] 胆小嘛，怕死。
[主播] 怂，比较。
[主播] 所以我每次在飞机上喜欢看这种历史书。
[主播] 我喜欢看那些变迁的历史里头，每一个孤独、勇敢、智慧、无畏、慷慨。
[主播] 或是自私、怯懦、卑鄙、愚蠢的个体。
[主播] 我们经常在看历史的时候，往往带着一种遗憾。
[主播] 我们在看历史的时候，往往带着一种过分的清醒和审判。
[主播] 但如果真的置身其中，我们就比他们做的更好吗？
[主播] 其实不是的。
[主播] 黄仁宇。
[主播] 他真的很会讲。
[主播] 他也真的很会写。
[主播] 所以这套书前几年特别火。
[主播] 万历十五年。
[主播] 明在中国历史上是一个非常特殊的时期。
[主播] 我用特殊的主要原因，第一个你说在很多的实力上来说。
[主播] 它强不强？它很强。
[主播] 但第二个它有没有按照我们后来所期待的阶段去发展？
[主播] 阶段去发展？又没有。
[主播] 为什么历史常常不如我们所期待的，那样的角度去发展？
[主播] 也许这本书能够给你一个更加清晰的审视。
[主播] 这套书完了，看完之后我特别感动的是这本书结尾的这句话，叫做
[主播] 他说也许每一个人都有自己独特的读法，每一个人都能读出自己的万历十五年。
[主播] 所以作者很清醒。
[主播] 他在鼓励思考。
[主播] 很多人只是想要讲一本，想要讲好一段故事，想要说清楚一段历史。
[主播] 但万历十五年这套书真的是能够读出很多不同的东西的。
[主播] 做企业管理的人在其中能读出企业管理的东西。
[主播] 每一个普通人能读出历史的兴衰或者是做人的一些道理。
[主播] 孩子可以从其中读到一些考试的知识。
[主播] 每个人都可以从其中看到自己想看到的东西。
[主播] 万历十五年，如果说大家没有读过的朋友，我强烈推荐自己去看啊。
[主播] 还有刚才所说的这个，我刚提到的人类简史。
[主播] 人类简史，今日简史以及未来简史。
[主播] 赫拉利史。
[主播] 赫拉利当年在哈佛大学毕业的时候非常年轻。
[主播] 他是一个极其年轻的优秀的学者。
[主播] 现在在希伯来大学这个教书，就是以色列，Israel。
[主播] 他写这套书也是前些年都已经很火很火了。
[主播] 我们现在给大家找的其实大部分都是一些非常经典的数，因为自己看过，觉得确实好。
[主播] 才想在这里给大家继续推荐。
[主播] 人类简史呢，从一个全新的视角去分析了我们为什么走到今天。
[主播] 赫拉利的勇敢之处在于他提出了很多闻所未闻的，前所未有的观点。
[主播] 比如说他说不是人类驯化的小麦，是小麦驯化的人。
[主播] 对吧，他甚至举例说不是人驯化的猫，是猫故意接近你。
[主播] 让你开始养它。
[主播] 猫的眼睛大大的像婴儿。
[主播] 猫叫的声音也像婴儿。
[主播] 因此唤醒了你对它这个怜悯之心，你爱它。
[主播] 所以你愿意给他买很多的好吃的，你把他当主子一样去供养。
[主播] 对吧，赫拉利甚至提到说人就是因为贪恋小麦。
[主播] 所以要定居下来。
[主播] 以前你那么自由的在打猎。
[主播] 但是你为了定居下来，为了养那个种那个小麦，为了贪那一口碳水化合物给你身体带来的快感。
[主播] 你得弯下腰去捡石头。
[主播] 因为那个会影响小麦的根系。
[主播] 你得灌溉。
[主播] 要不然小麦会渴死。
[主播] 你甚至还在那里为了争更多的土地，得与其他的族人去开始战争，去抢夺资源。
[主播] 赫拉利说是小麦驯化的人类。
[主播] 说玩之后当然他这个观点也遭到了各界的批评，一度猛喷。
[主播] 但我还挺喜欢的。
[主播] 我很喜欢看到一些前所未有的观点，因为我觉得在这些前所未有的观点里头才有人类积极的探索和大胆的尝试。
[主播] 他在后来提到未来简史的时候，其实也提到了人类更多以后要面对的问题。
[主播] 比如说我们的子孙们可能要真正去面临到人类新议题。
[主播] 他甚至还讲到了我们以后要经历的，可能会经历的，就是智人失去控制权。
[主播] 他提到了数据对于人类的影响。
[主播] 他甚至提出一种非常悲观的观点说以后啊，可能我们就
[主播] 不用大脑思考了，不用这些大脑里头的放电反应了，因为你思考、记忆、情感、心动啊。
[主播] 其实都是这种大脑的放电反应。
[主播] 他觉得以后我们不需要了。
[主播] 有可能啊，有可能我们讨论一下。
[主播] 有可能你把你人的决策权交给一片硅。
[主播] 就是芯片嘛，芯片就是很薄很薄的硅刻上槽子之后。
[主播] 有可能你看到了身边走过的女孩你很心动，你看到她微笑的样子，穿着裙子从你身边走过，空气里是她留下头发好闻的味道。
[主播] 你很心动。
[主播] 但是呢，他告诉这个芯片告诉你，说不适合。
[主播] 你们俩有诸多的各种不适合。
[主播] 你是会坚持自己的判断，还是听芯片的建议？
[主播] 我当时听完这段话之后，我突然有一种
[主播] 自己的判断还是听芯片的建议。
[主播] 我当时听完这段话之后，我突然有一种很悲观的思考啊。
[主播] 因为大家知道现在AI的发展速度太快了。
[主播] AI的速度发展快到以至于很多时候人的智力是彻底跟不上的，人的计算能力和判断准确度也确实跟不上。
[主播] 从安全的角度去说，如果是全部是自动驾驶，然后反应速度也足够快的话，其实能避免大量的交通事故。
[主播] 因为大量的交通事故都是出于人的误判。
[主播] 但你的误判一般，你的判断往往都是有误判的可能性存在，对吧？
[主播] 你要么判断对的，要么判断错了。
[主播] 那如果有一天我们可以把方向盘交给机器人。
[主播] 我们有一天是不是也可以把餐桌交给机器人？
[主播] 我们将来是不是也可以把生育交给机器人？
[主播] 那坦诚来说从人物种的延续上，如果把生育都交给机器人了。
[主播] 是否还有爱情存在的必要？
[主播] 想到这块突然还觉得
[主播] 还挺有意思的啊，略带悲观，但我觉得挺有意思的。
[主播] 我在想真的会这样吗？
[主播] 我很好奇。
[主播] 如果能满足我一个无理的要求。
[主播] 我希望我能穿越到100年后看一看。
[主播] 我看看100年后人们还是会如我们现在这样，看到心动的人会约他出来，约会、看电影、吃饭、散步、聊天。
[主播] 准备精心的礼物，认真的写一份情书。
[主播] 还是说大家通过大数据筛选，好，你们俩。
[主播] 宣布在一起了。
[主播] 我我很好奇人类未来会怎么走向。
[主播] 这些议题当然不是我们现在决定的。
[主播] 这些议题当然是以后子孙们去决定的。
[主播] 前提是子孙们去天思考的这种问题。
[主播] 人在遇到没有经验的事情的时候，都容易发生误判。
[主播] 所以未来简史这本书可以让你去思考那些问题，思考准确的你可能就不误判了。
[主播] 第一次会摔倒。
[主播] 但第二次可能不一定了。
[主播] 有朋友说我没有声音了。
[主播] 我这现在正常吗，导演你听一下。
[其他] 正常。
[主播] 你听的是正常的，是吧？
[其他] 他们卡了。
[主播] OK。
[主播] 还有朋友说卡，但是我们现场导演这说的是正常的。
[主播] 如果是卡，你可以退出试试重进一下就行，好吗？
[主播] 万历十五年讲的是一段历史。
[主播] 万古江河讲的是中华文明。
[主播] 不是一本书。
[主播] 不是一个事情啊。
[主播] 想看的朋友自己去拍吧，嗯。
[主播] 如果卡的话，你可以试着退出重进一下就行，好吧？
[主播] 有朋友说董大明白，你才29岁，不要想的太明白。
[主播] 确实有时候你好像什么都想明白的时候，就人生就容易不快乐了。
[主播] 看得太透了嘛。
[主播] 就是活着那套书，那本那个书，那个故事不是有一个说少年想游荡，少年之心在四方嘛。
[主播] 曾梦想仗剑走天涯，所以少年想游荡。
[主播] 然后呢，中年想绝葬，是吧？
[主播] 挖宝藏，想发财。
[主播] 老年呢，当和尚，想通了。
[主播] 没有追求了。
[主播] 来，农产品，接下来给大家带来一个黑枸杞原浆啊。
[主播] 没事没事，你放，我自己拿，OK,谢谢。
[主播] 黑枸杞原浆。
[主播] 莫小吉的黑枸杞原浆。
[主播] 前两天就给大家推荐了。
[主播] 我不知道你们买的收到了没？
[主播] 一盒里头有十包，一包有30毫升，宁夏的黑枸杞啊。
[主播] 宁夏是非常经典的枸杞产地。
[主播] 因为大家都知道在黄河的河滩上。
[主播] 所以奔腾的黄河水携带了很多细腻的土壤。
[主播] 土壤积淀之后呢，土质深厚，土里肥沃。
[主播] 所以能够长出特别好的东西。
[主播] 又因为宁夏常年比较干燥，少雨，光照时间长，所以宁夏的枸杞自古以来就很出名。
[主播] 那黑枸杞呢，其实以前是青海中的多一些。
[主播] 但他们家的黑枸杞也是宁夏的。
[主播] 里头的配料也非常的干净，大家看一下。
[主播] 这里只有这个枸杞。
[主播] 只有黑枸杞啊。
[主播] 撕开之后呢，是酸甜口感，特别好喝。
[主播] 导演给我个杯子，我给大家展示一下啊。
[主播] 酱果色。
[主播] 我们喜欢这个，有朋友说宁夏不产黑枸杞。
[主播] 这个上面写的是他们是宁夏产的啊。
[主播] 它可能宁夏不产，但它可能是传统意义上不产，它可能是在宁夏现在在种的啊。
[主播] 以前我们所说的黑枸杞确实是这个青海的多一些啊。
[主播] 黑枸杞的特点啥？
[主播] 黑色其实就是花青素。
[主播] 花青素能干什么？
[主播] 你说能干什么？
[主播] 花青素有什么我不能说啊，你自己需要自己去拍。
[主播] 大家可以看一下这个特别特殊的颜色。
[主播] 有一些颜色天然就能给人带来喜悦，比如说琥珀。
[主播] 比如说这种紫色。
[主播] 黑枸杞的这种紫，黑紫色。
[主播] 然后有一种浓浓的味道。
[主播] 这个味道应该是某种氨基酸的味道，我觉得应该是。
[主播] 然后酸甜口感，特别好喝。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 很舒服。
[主播] 喜欢喝的朋友自己去拍啊。
[主播] 黑枸杞，包括大家所知道的像蓝莓，这一类深色的东西都富含大量的花青素。
[主播] 花青素有什么用，刚才评论区已经有朋友给你说了。
[主播] 因为那几个字是违禁词，所以我一个都不能提。
[主播] 喜欢的朋友自己去拍就行。
[主播] 只要是你自己喜欢的，让自己能够感到舒服的东西，应该都是对的。
[主播] 短暂的一生里不要尝试去讨好每一个人。
[主播] 因为做不到。
[主播] 永远有人不喜欢你。
[主播] 他甚至可以不喜欢你长得样子。
[主播] 他不喜欢你说话的样子。
[主播] 他不喜欢你吃饭的样子。
[主播] 他甚至可以不喜欢你走路的样子。
[主播] 你为什么要去讨好他？
[主播] 讨好你自己就行。
[主播] 喜欢就喝。
[主播] 想听就听。
[主播] 想看就看。
[主播] 想见就去见。
[主播] 何必要听他的说。
[主播] 千万不要把自己短暂的一生都用来去讨好别人啊，朋友们。
[主播] 想到这一点你才能活得通透，你才能豁达一些。
[主播] 黑枸杞原浆，富含花青素。
[主播] 献给屏幕前每一个想让自己快乐的朋友。
[主播] 人生的意义在于取悦自己。
[主播] 千万不要搞反了。
[主播] 除了黑枸杞原浆以外，接下来给大家带来的叫baby南瓜。
[主播] Baby pumpkin。
[主播] 南瓜很小，因为它的品种就是这样子的啊。
[主播] 它不是说没长大。
[主播] 洗一下，切成块，然后呢，可以蒸。
[主播] 也可以放到空气炸锅里炸一切吗？
[主播] 如果你用空气炸锅尝这个，口感会特别好。
[主播] 撒一些这个橄榄油，然后弄一点点这个盐，还有一些黑胡椒的这个这样拧一些黑胡椒的粉。
[主播] 放到空气炸锅里去做一下。
[主播] 我们之前在直播间里试过一次。
[主播] 做完之后呢，外表是酥脆的口感。
[主播] 又因为有橄榄油的香，所以唇齿之间留下了一种特别难忘的味道。
[主播] 紧接着你的牙齿在咬的时候，能感觉到它板栗的口感。
[主播] 很软。
[主播] 外表是酥脆的，里头是软糯的板栗口感。
[主播] 你的舌尖上每一个味蕾瞬间被唤醒，因为你的唾液里有1%的酶。
[主播] 那个酶呢，会把一些碳水化合物转化为葡萄糖。
[主播] 所以吃在嘴里还有一丝淡淡的回甘。
[主播] 很难相信这是一个简单的南瓜给你带来如此丰富的味觉体验。
[主播] 我刚才把做的方告诉你了。
[主播] 切成小的角，撒上橄榄油，淋上一点点的盐和一些这个黑胡椒的那个拧那个黑胡椒的东西。
[主播] 黑胡椒的粉，你试一次。
[主播] 试一次就好了。
[主播] 有朋友说我在人间贩卖理想。
[主播] 我是在人间贩卖理想。
[主播] 我也在人间贩卖生活。
[主播] 生活可以简单到就是一个精致的baby pumpkin。
[主播] 你用刚才那个方式去试试做一下。
[主播] 简单的食物也能带来喜悦。
[主播] 山药。
[主播] 我们这个山药可能。
[其他] 啊，这是温县的山药是吧？
[其他] 对。
[主播] 那这个山药已经很出名了。
[主播] 咱这个山药长芽是因为咱放的时间长了吗？
[主播] 还是他们收到也会有长芽？
[其他] 放的时间很长了，我们收到可能要有一个月了，这个样子。
[主播] 咱在直播间也放了一个月了。
[主播] 大家收到不会有长芽吧？
[其他] 不会。
[主播] 因为这种东西如果一长芽的话，可能就比较危险。
[主播] 啊，这个才是真的样品。
[主播] 啊，那这个看着正常一些。
[主播] 你可以把这个拿走吗？谢谢。
[主播] 谢谢。
[主播] 山药。
[主播] 很长的，完整的一根啊。
[主播] 山药也分的有那种特别粗的那种山药。
[主播] 那种山药一般是脆的。
[主播] 然后呢，细的山药呢，往往它是能够蒸或者煮完了，它是有那种糯的口感的。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 那种山药一般是脆的，然后呢，细的山药呢，往往它是能够蒸或者煮完了，它是有那种糯的口感的。
[主播] 然后里头也给大家带来这个削山药的这个小的刀子，啊。
[主播] 然后还有这个山药粉，如果大家自己喜欢冲的话，可以拿它试着冲一下。
[主播] 山药有很好的这个作用，但是我在镜头前一个都不能说。因为大家都知道啊，所以我一个都不能说。想知道的可以自己去拍就行。
[主播] 刚才那个是因为我们放的时间久了，跟山药本身没有关系啊。
[主播] 这个山药是没事的。
[嘉宾] 我们售后是肯定没有问题的。
[主播] 售后是没问题的啊。
[主播] 有的朋友如果是确实有朋友可能会对山药的这个汁液有一些过敏，如果过敏的话，你就带着一个手套去去削就行了，家里有那种塑料手套也行。
[主播] 因为大家知道这个在我们传统中国的饮食文化中山药对于人身体是有一些其他的这个好处的，但是那些呢全部都是一些违禁词。不语许说，所以我不能介绍，如果大家喜欢的话，可以在评论区全说，给其他朋友们提醒一下就行。
[主播] 呃，山药有个非常好的做法就是削完皮之后切成段，然后去蒸对吧？蒸出来之后放一点点那个。
[嘉宾] 糖。
[主播] 糖。蜂蜜，桂花酱，或者是蓝莓的果酱，也可以。还有一个其实就是直接把这个煮粥。Yes。
[嘉宾] 炖排骨。
[嘉宾] 煲汤。
[嘉宾] 糖醋。
[主播] 糖醋吗？这个可以糖醋吗？
[嘉宾] 可以。
[主播] 我没吃过。
[嘉宾] 清炒木耳。
[主播] 还可以清炒，对，清炒木耳我吃过，拿山药跟木耳清炒可以。很健康的食物啊。
[嘉宾] 拔丝。
[主播] 山药什么？
[嘉宾] 山药排骨汤。
[主播] 山药排骨汤，Yes。
[嘉宾] 拔丝山药。
[主播] 我会做拔丝红薯。
[主播] 对。不会做菜的新东方老师不是好销售。
[主播] 然后我以前给大家讲过，我说我在刚毕业那两年，因为当时特别穷嘛，跟其他两个老师合租。然后呢，每次回家之后因为自己要自己做饭吃，因为那样的为了省钱，要不然生活费不够。我当时记得我给他们还做过这个拔丝红薯。浪费了很多的油，你要先把红薯炸成软的块，就炸炸里头熟了，然后再去起那个倒入糖，然后起那个沫，等它起沫的时候，你不能太早，因为太早的话，它那个沫没有起来，可能这个就拉不出来丝了，因为糖没有彻底融化。你也不能太晚，因为太晚了，糖就糊了，它就苦了。它就苦了。
[主播] 它就是那个对，焦糖色，它刚起沫的时候，然后赶紧把那个炸好的红薯块倒进去。不是，我在卖山药呢，我怎么讲红薯。大家可以试着用山药去做一下拔丝的，导演刚才说可以拔丝，你们可以试一下啊。
[主播] 我我当时就是那样试的，而且成功了，成功一次，信心大增，然后以后一直那样做，糟蹋了很多的油，嗯。
[嘉宾] 你浪费的油是你对美好的向往。
[主播] 哎呀，导演说那不叫浪费啊，那是对美好的向往，嗯。
[主播] 这个就是大家所知道的温县的山药啊。
[主播] 很经典的这个产地的山药。
[嘉宾] 这个是礼盒装的，不然也可以。
[主播] 礼盒装的是吧？
[主播] 焦作。
[嘉宾] 我们平时吃的同学还说可以做第三鲜。
[主播] 第三鲜，对对对对对，第三鲜。
[主播] 山药像这种初级农产品啊，大家就不用担心了。
[主播] 初级农产品一般它都这个基本上从地里出来，可能中间再经一层就是这个快递小哥，啊。
[主播] 有朋友说这个有咖啡吗？我们现在有咖啡吗？
[主播] 如果有的你给他谈，如果没有的话就算了，好吧。
[主播] 想要的朋友自己去拍啊，这个是山药。OK。
[主播] 来下一个是 有机玉米粉，玉米糊。
[主播] 各位朋友们，食物分为普通的和比如说我们所说的绿色的那些还有有机的。有机的产品它确实本来成本就高。这个玉米粉是可以早餐起来冲一下的，直接冲成糊。就像大家去吃一个叫李先生的牛肉我本人吃过，牛肉面吃过吗？它里头就有一个玉米糊。就那个喝着玉米糊的那个玉米汁。其实你拿这个冲一下，口感比那个甚至会更好一些，因为我前两天试过一次。
[主播] 很简单，直接把它冲开。你可以拿一个透明的杯子，我可以把它倒出来给大家展示一下吗？
[主播] 然后热水直接冲就行，非常的方便。有一种甜味。
[主播] 有机玉米粉啊，它的配料只有一个东西就是玉米，有机玉米啊。
[主播] 哈哈，这个颜色可能大家看不太出来。
[主播] 大家看到了没？等我给个近景看一下啊。
[主播] 直接用热水冲就行，玉米粉。
[主播] 哎，不好意思。
[主播] 洒了一些。
[主播] 非常方便，然后自己早餐可以吃。或者下午你在办公室里突然感觉到自己反应速度有些慢，然后有点缺能量，你也可以。因为我因为常年睡眠差，而且这个饮食也不太好，胃口不太好，所以我经常在下午可能办公室里工作的工作，我突然发现自己就脑子反应速度很慢，就困了就。然后我这个时候我就会干嘛？我就会去迅速补充一些糖嘛，对吧？你要么喝一点可乐那些东西。或者你可以冲一个这个玉米糊，玉米粉。因为它它能迅速补充你身体的这个碳水化合物，最终其实转化成了一些葡萄糖，啊。
[嘉宾] 对，这个身体的，有腰，对吧，热量比较低一些。
[主播] 这个热量比较低是吧？
[嘉宾] 一包的话是等于一个苹果的热量。
[主播] 一包等于一个苹果的热量。OK。
[嘉宾] 它还有一股奶香味，我那天泡了一杯。
[嘉宾] 奶香味，泡了。
[主播] 导演偷偷喝了一次是吧，有奶香味啊。确实口感挺好的，我那天也喝过一次，嗯。
[主播] 如果你从来没有尝过这个玉米糊啊，你可以试一次。试一次，还挺喜欢的。
[主播] 有朋友说大脑思考需要糖分，对，很多人说这个为什么吃完那些会困。注意，你困是因为你吃的太多了。你不管吃什么，吃多你都会困，因为你吃太多了之后你肠胃消化，它是需要这个蠕动的对吧？你血液就大量的就在肠胃附近的，你大脑缺血造成的困。并不是因为你这个吃了这个淀粉导致你困。不管你吃什么，只要吃多你都容易困，因为你大脑缺血了。然后但另外一个，其实很多时候大家我们说不要过度的或者单纯的吃米面这种东西，不要单纯只吃碳水，因为碳水吃太多了，你身体胰岛素提前就被消耗光了。人类在百万年的进化过程中，其实你想大量吃的是什么？是肉啊，对吧？你打打猎或者吃的一些果子或者草啊这些东西，其实吃这些你身体已经适应。人类驯化小麦和水稻都是一万年以内的事情。人类能把水水稻小麦吃饱都是几十年的事情。你想想几十年前，百年前以前，有多少人说他真能想吃多少就吃饱的，对吧？没有那么大的科技和农业技术的发展是不可能支撑当时那么多人的那个需求的。所以以前是很难吃饱的，现在因为米和面吃太饱了，迅速吃太饱了，所以大家会出现各种血糖的问题。这个如果血糖有问题的朋友就不要拍了啊。
[主播] 因为玉米它肯定还是淀粉。
[主播] 然后呢，刚才大家又提到一个点，就是人是需要这个这个淀粉的，是肯定的，因为它会转化为葡萄糖，然后我之前给大家说过，人在思考呀，回忆呀这种，其实你的神经元它只能消耗比较小的这种营养，你像葡萄糖就可以，但你像脂肪啊，蛋白质它就太大颗粒了，你的神经元是没有办法消化掉的。
[嘉宾] 这个拍光了。
[主播] 拍光了是吧？
[嘉宾] 补不了。
[主播] 喜欢的朋友可以自己去试一下啊。
[主播] 这是一些小知识啊。
[主播] 高高，高中可能学过吧，高中没学过的话，其实我也不是高中学的，我是后来看一本书叫做考神脑科学里头提到的。
[主播] 来下一个是95纯虾排。虾饼。
[主播] 稍微在锅里头煎一下就好了。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 虾仁、淀粉、鸡蛋清、白砂糖、食用盐、植物油、味精等。
[嘉宾] 老师你知道为什么叫95纯虾排？
[主播] 啊？
[嘉宾] 为什么叫95纯虾排？
[主播] 那是因为虾仁的含量在95%以上啊。所以剩下的5%就是一些比如说动物脂肪啊或者蛋清。大家知道一般虾滑里头都必要放一点点猪的肥膘或者蛋清，为什么？因为不放那两个，虾煮的时候就会散开，散开的话，就凝结不到一块了，口感就不怎么好了。所以大家把这个蛋清和猪肉肥膘加在里头的时候，它煮第一个不会散开，第二个完了它的口感会更加的Q弹，而且能吃的更香一些，因为你想嘛，香味嘛，对吧？鸡蛋会让它凝结，猪肉肥膘会给它提供一种汁水，并且散发出香味，所以这就是通常做法。一般情况下，比如说就看那两个加的多少的，比如说那两个加的少一点，那虾的含量就得高，那两个加的多一点，虾的含量就少，仅此而已。今天是给大家有什么送的是吧？
[嘉宾] 送那个番茄沙司两个。
[主播] Sauce，OK，番茄酱两个。
[主播] 沙司，Sauce，like ketchup，ketchup就是番茄酱的意思啊。
[主播] 番茄沙司。
[主播] 怎么做都好吃，全家人都爱吃。家里有小孩的话，其实可以自己拍一些。或者你自己是一个特别精致的，热爱食物，热爱一些精致食物的朋友，你也可以试一试，因为虾本身都是高蛋白低脂肪的这个食物。比较方便，稍微锅里头倒一些油低温煎一下，不要温度太高，温度太高可能就煎糊了。喜欢的朋友自己去拍啊。
[主播] 还有玉米粉，玉米粉咱现在是不是没有了？
[嘉宾] 没有了，卖光了。
[嘉宾] 我们大概明天的话，明天的话有一个安全库存是有限的。
[主播] 每天的安全库存是有限的，因为是，我们现在直播间里还有接近30万人呢。就是不管什么产品在我们直播间里，农产品啊，就迅速就空了。大家又得知道农产品没有办法像工业制成品一样，你今天说3000，马力全开3000，你要3万，几个生产线马力全开3万都行。农产品很多时候它的特点就是你得保持克制和耐心，喜欢是放肆，但爱是克制，农产品就是爱。它是克制，就比如说这个地方今天只有5000单，想要再要，没有。种不出来。
[主播] 来下一个是褚橙的橙汁啊。
[主播] NFC。
[主播] NFC就是not from concentrated，not from concentrated什么意思呢？
[主播] Concentrated叫做浓缩的。
[主播] Concentrated，n叫做not from concentrated。叫NFC。
[主播] 这是不是来自浓缩的。
[主播] 为什么会这么说呢？大家知道在果汁这个行业里头，其实我们以前可能喝果汁喝的少一些。国外人喝果汁喝的特别多，对吧？It's like everybody drink juice or milk for breakfast。
[主播] 果汁在运输和保存的过程中，你得降低成本，所以他们就浓缩。所以以前榨出来可能是十杯，我浓缩之后是一杯，我只运输这一杯，加工这一杯。然后我需要卖给你的时候，你再我在再临时加水就行了，它其实就是经过了浓缩再加水的一个过程。那那样它其实减少的是中间的很多运输和保存的成本，但是却影响了一些口感，或者是营养啊。然后呢，现在就流行这种NFC，就是not from concentrated的意思，其实就是它就是直接鲜榨的原汁，没有经过中间的浓缩，也没有经过二次的加水。它本来就保留了当时榨出来果汁的口感和味道。
[主播] OK。
[主播] NFC就是not from concentrated的褚橙。
[主播] 我相信每个人应该都曾经被褚老爷子的故事感动过。
[主播] 一个男的可以被打倒，但是他得有再次站起来的这种精神。
[主播] 褚老爷子他知道，等他确实犯了一些不该犯的错，这个我们必须承认的啊，曾经。
[主播] 家里很穷，兄弟几个都很穷，都到了那么大年龄的时候，生活还是很苦。
[主播] 后来做了云南卷烟厂的厂长，效益特别好。
[主播] 他在退休的时候呢，决定跟兄弟们分一笔钱，不应该分的钱。
[主播] 后来就进了监狱。
[主播] 70多岁，保外就医。
[主播] 我时常在想，如果我人生突然走误入了一段歧途，我会怎么样后悔。
[主播] 我就如之前给大家所描述的，在风雨交加的夜里，喝醉了，拍着自己肌肉松弛的大腿，告诉我的子孙说，爷爷这一生就到此为止了。
[主播] 爷爷曾经辉煌过。
[主播] 爷爷也失落过，爷爷贫穷过，爷爷也富裕过。对不起，爷爷犯了错。
[主播] 很有可能很多人的故事就那样一生就结束了。
[主播] 好几天后带着遗憾就结束了。
[主播] 但褚老爷子不是。
[主播] 他决定要再次东山再起。
[主播] 很多时候他甚至就只是不愿意输给自己。
[主播] 扛着锄头上山种橙子。
[主播] 他种橙子那个山特别的硬景叫做哀牢山。
[主播] 你注意这几个字，哀牢山。在云南。
[主播] 一个70多岁的老人愿意上山种橙子来完成自己的二次创业。
[主播] 我在第一次听到这个故事时，我无法理解，我说你是有多大的勇气与智慧，你敢藐视生命带来的苦难，或者你逐渐老去的身体。
[主播] 你上山种橙子去，你想挣钱来点来点快的呀。
[主播] 这就是一个人笃定和自信，他选择了上山种橙子。
[主播] 橙子终于挂果了，发现品质不太好，毁了，再种。
[主播] 我听到那里我更觉得优秀了。
[主播] 我是无论如何没有这样的勇气的。
[主播] 所以我们时常在读一些人的故事的时候，好像也从侧面提醒了自己。提醒了自己应该是怎么去做。
[主播] 98块钱12瓶，因为是NFC，它确实相比普通的果汁成本要高一些。
[主播] 我后来在当老师的时候，曾经给我班里的学生们讲过这段故事。
[主播] 我说
[主播] 不要害怕人生会摔倒。
[主播] 不要害怕人生偶尔会误入歧途。
[主播] 只要你始终心怀希望与坚定，你终将能够走在阳光明媚的路上。
[主播] 请我们不要忘记那个70多岁扛着锄头上山种橙子的老人。
[主播] 他在91岁还是92岁那一年离开的。前几年其实，时间不久。
[主播] 褚橙后来被大家叫做励志橙。
[主播] 好像人们只要吃着他种的橙子的时候，都能从其中体会到他的品质一样。
[主播] 我们喜欢给食物赋予回忆，赋予美好。
[主播] 我们后来好像从褚老爷子的橙子中也赋予了这个橙子品质。
[主播] 就是那个经典的产地。
[主播] 就是那个恰到好处的海拔。
[主播] 就是那个独特的品种，因为其实云南那个冰糖橙其实并不大，它比较小，但是皮薄，酸甜度恰恰好。它不是纯甜，但它也不酸，酸甜度恰恰好。
[主播] 我当时在给孩子们讲的那段故事的时候，我告诉他们跟别人经历的苦难相比，可能一次两次你考试没有考好，其实根本没有那么大的影响，它一定不会影响到你一生。
[主播] 其实跟别人所经历的起落相比，那个女生不喜欢你，今天老师批评了你，妈妈责备了你。看起来都没那么重要。
[主播] 我以前在当老师的时候，总是喜欢絮絮叨叨，总是喜欢把这些事情教给自己的孩子们，因为我有时候看到一些孩子特别脆弱。
[主播] 大家时常会读到一些新闻，看很多孩子可能脆弱的时候，我其实内心是很痛苦的，我觉得一定是他的教育者们没有把话说给他。
[主播] 所以我以前当老师的时候，给很多孩子，给每一届的孩子都会去讲褚老爷子的故事，讲他的褚橙。
[主播] 现在不是种褚橙的时间啊，所以现在只能有这个鲜榨的这个橙汁。
[主播] 如果您自己喜欢的话，您可以去买，如果您觉得这个价格偏高呢，您也可以理性购物。完全看个人的需求去消费。
[嘉宾] Yes，那个是我的杯子，谢谢啊。
[嘉宾] 我们只有500单了。
[嘉宾] 卖完就没有办法补了。
[主播] 只剩500单了是吧？
[嘉宾] 是的。
[主播] 好。
[主播] 云南玉溪的。
[主播] 呃，如果有云南的朋友可能对褚老爷子故事要更了解一些。
[主播] 所以我后来给孩子们讲，我说人生短期拼的是智力。
[主播] 聪明重要不？聪明重要。
[主播] 但因为聪明就一定能成功吗？其实不是，很多人就因为太聪明了，一眼就看清楚了，很多事情其实可以是投机取巧的。
[主播] 所以总是寻求投机取巧，以至于最后聪明反被聪明误。
[主播] 人生短期拼的是智力。
[主播] 中期啊，其实拼的是毅力。
[主播] 总是比别人扛打。
[主播] 总是比别人扛造。
[主播] 总是比别人充满了韧性。
[主播] 所以总是能够从谷底再次跃起。
[主播] 短期拼智力，中期拼毅力，长期拼体力。想喝一个是吧？
[嘉宾] 因为我们这边已经卖光了。
[主播] 已经卖光了，没法卖了，所以样品也不用了，所以你喝了是吧？厂商这个样品退不了，对不起，导演喝了。
[主播] 我喝这瓶是属于正常耗损，你喝这个就完全属于。
[嘉宾] 不属于你的正常耗损。
[主播] 长期拼体力啊。
[主播] 只有到了六七十岁的时候，你才知道一个好的身体是多么的重要。
[主播] 那时候你拥有大量的时间，手头可能还有一点点钱。你想吃，想玩，想去看这个世界。
[主播] 你后来才发现其实你的身体已经不行了。
[主播] 等一会29岁，好像讲出来一个92岁人的故事。
[嘉宾] 来了来了，来补库存了，厂商反应太快了。
[主播] 厂商说有库存是吧？厂商反应太快了，那你直接上吧。嗯。
[嘉宾] 来，我再还给你。
[主播] 因为虽然，你喝吧，你喝吧，你喝吧，那一单我掏了，嗯。虽然我才29岁，但是我确实身体像92岁，因为常年失眠，浑身疼。所以尤其在那个时候，我就给他们说，人生长期一定拼的是体力。
[主播] 真的是在拼体力。
[主播] 我现在就明显感觉体力比之前差好多。
[主播] 我在25岁之前生猛，特别生猛。
[主播] 真的是生龙活虎那种猛。
[主播] 熬夜，没事。
[主播] 连续工作十几个小时，没事。
[主播] 失眠了睡不着，我干脆起床去跑步，一直跑到天亮，没事。
[主播] 那会饭量也还可以。
[主播] 但现在我迅速发现自己身体变差了。
[主播] 人生长期一定拼的是体力。
[主播] 有时候人生会难一段时间，但一定不要忘记好好吃饭，好好睡觉。
[主播] 你的身体比什么都重要。比什么都重要。
[主播] OK。
[主播] 万古江河适合七年级吗？七年级可以。
[主播] 那就是初一，为什么叫七年级呢？
[主播] 七岁还是七年级？如果七岁的话，可能有点有点难了啊。
[主播] 人生短期拼智力，中期拼毅力，长期拼体力。
[主播] 七岁还是七年级，如果七岁的话，可能有点有点难了啊。
[主播] 到最后他
[主播] 人生短期拼智力，中期拼毅力，长期拼体力。
[主播] 到最后都是体力的较量。
[主播] 所以我以前给大家举个例子，你看这个我我曾经这个听说过余老师，有一次吃完余老师讲他一天的这个工作量。
[主播] 早上起来说是先跑步好像是，跑步5公里。
[主播] 然后呢，来新东方处理工作，中午呢坐飞机，因为下午有新东方地方学校20年校庆，他要去讲话。
[主播] 然后呢，可能还有饭间还要吃吃饭还要敬他一些酒。
[主播] 完了之后他到那个地方了，他的一些好朋友知道，说那你来我们那个好朋友是个大学校长，你来我们大学做一场演讲，他要去演讲。
[主播] 演讲完了之后呢，晚上因为他要给一些地方捐学校，当地的一些对接的部门，他们要去这个去开会，完了晚上又去吃饭，还要喝一些酒。
[主播] 特别晚的时候又回到晚上北京，然后在这个回来是坐的高铁，好像说是，在高铁上突然意识到说自己今天运动量不够。
[主播] 原地跑步3000步。
[其他] 原地跑。
[主播] 对，其实在高铁上嘛，两个车厢中间嘛，你没有办法在高铁来回窜嘛。
[主播] 这个跑完了之后晚上回到自己家里，发现今天还没有读书。
[主播] 于是开始要看今天的书，他当时还每天更新他那个文章的嘛。
[主播] 读完书了，已经深夜几点了。
[主播] 我当时第一次听完之后，我发现我说我天，如果一个人能够持续好多年这样去修炼自己，他不可能不成功，我当时想我必须要像余老师靠近，我要开始折磨自己，我要虐自己。
[主播] 我坚持到第三天，我发现我放弃，我必须得放弃，我为了长久的发展，我得珍惜自己的身体。
[主播] 所以后来我发现那些得天独厚者，真的有的时候就是体力惊人，智力也惊人，毅力也惊人。
[主播] 你羡慕，你只要修炼一个好吗？
[主播] 智力不是说天生像来的智商，你有一个学习力，一直去读书，一直去探索，一直去与人交流，向人学习，这叫智力。
[主播] 毅力就是不放弃，敢于再次孤身划着自己的小船，走入那片大海里，去捕获属于自己的鱼。
[主播] 体力很简单，锻炼好你的身体，好好吃饭，好好睡觉，让自己时刻处于一个比较好的状态。
[主播] 这些都很重要。
[其他] 烧麦。
[主播] 这个是烧麦对吧，我给拍一下，我拿这么，忘了，烧麦。
[主播] 喜欢的朋友可以去拍，这个烧麦里头呢，首先是糯米，然后呢有腊肠，除了腊肠以外，还有这个笋，大家都知道这个烧麦里头有的有时候是笋，有的可能是这个熏肉，然后有腊肠。
[主播] 口感还是非常好。
[主播] 这个是猪肉和笋丁的，它口感不一样啊。
[主播] 看，这个叫做腊肠的加蛋黄的，这个是鲜肉的。
[主播] 小馄饨。
[主播] 然后这个是纸皮的烧麦。
[主播] 这个烧麦是这个麦呢，应该是烧麦的麦不应该是小麦的麦吗？
[主播] 是吧？
[其他] 小麦的麦。
[主播] 那可能是它的品牌就这个，是吧？
[主播] 笋丁的糯米的。
[主播] 笋丁蛋黄的。
[主播] 荠菜鲜肉的。
[其他] 你可以拆一下给大家看。
[主播] 拆一点是吧？
[主播] 好。
[其他] 拆一个蛋黄的。
[主播] 是，我拆的是蛋黄的，哇天，这么明显的蛋黄，大家看一下。
[主播] 烧麦看一下。
[主播] 喜欢的朋友自己去拍啊。
[主播] 嗯，很香啊，我能看到这个蛋黄的样子。
[其他] 蛋黄的有点流油的。
[主播] 确实，你想一想，这个烧麦是蒸吗？
[其他] 蒸的，蒸的。
[主播] 蒸是吧？
[主播] 蒸完之后呢，这个表皮很软，里头的米很糯，又加上这个蛋黄和腊肠的味道，香，然后冒出一点点油。
[其他] 我们到手是六袋，就桌上的都是你的。
[主播] 桌上的这六袋都是啊。
[主播] 我刚拆了一袋嘛，这不还有五袋嘛，再加上这袋一共六袋啊。
[其他] 一会再多解决掉。
[主播] 这个是冷链发货，冷链发货。
[主播] 喜欢的朋友自己去拍。
[主播] 烧麦如果是喜欢的朋友，他会特别喜欢这个口感的，如果你从来没有尝过，其实我比较建议你试一次。
[主播] 我以前其实也没吃过烧麦，北方人不太吃嘛。
[主播] 我们在这视频的时候，我尝完一次，我发现哎呀，真喜欢，尤其对于一个西北人来说，因为我们是碳水狂魔，对吧？
[主播] 米啊面，你知道陕西人是可以用馍去夹凉皮的，用饼子夹凉皮的，用碳水加碳水，大家很喜欢这种碳水混合在一起的味道。
[主播] 但是这个里头因为它有腊肠啊，蛋黄啊，或者是很多肉啊，以及笋丁啊，以及有时候还有香菇那些，所以又香又好吃，而且迅速补充到体力。
[主播] 喜欢的朋友自己去拍啊。
[主播] 有朋友说这个想看帅哥顿顿是吧？
[主播] 我一会结束之后是谁今天？
[其他] 帅哥明明。
[主播] 是明明。
[其他] 叫什么？那个词打出来。
[主播] 明明你就不要用帅哥这两个词。
[主播] 有的时候呢，我们确实希望孩子看到世界的美好。
[主播] 我们想让孩子心怀善良走在阳光里。
[主播] 但我们不能用一个有色的滤镜去过分的修饰这个世界。
[主播] 我们必须让孩子有时候要清醒而理性的看到这个世界时常是残忍的。
[主播] 比如这个世界的美好在于有东东顿顿这样的帅哥，有人杰西这样才华横溢的老师。
[主播] 也偶尔会出现一两个像董宇辉和石门这样的丑八怪。
[主播] 虽然长相上有一些面目可憎，但他们内心还是柔软而善良。
[主播] 也因为读了那么多读那么一两本书，时常呢也能说出一点点的道理。
[主播] 石门老师比我幸运在。
[其他] 他有老婆。
[其他] 老婆。
[其他] 我给你一个老婆你要不要？
[其他] 认养一头牛高端酸奶。
[主播] 这个转折一点都不尴尬。
[其他] 很丝滑。
[主播] 很丝滑，很柔顺，我相信屏幕前的每个朋友都感觉到这个里头深刻的逻辑，多么清晰，多合理啊。
[主播] 先刺激，再认养一头牛。
[主播] 喜欢的朋友自己去拍啊。
[主播] 很好。
[主播] 哎，这个味道叫白桃燕麦。
[其他] 对。
[主播] 我给大家试一下。
[主播] 导演你还想试吗？
[其他] 可以吗？
[主播] 不可以。
[其他] 好的。
[主播] 你知道为什么不可以吗？
[其他] 因为我刚才话你说了吗？然后你内心纯良，但是表面要装作善良。
[其他] 这就是你吗老师？
[主播] 你还年轻啊，导演，你还不知道这个世界有很多像我一样小肚鸡肠的人。
[主播] 敢在我面前刺激我，还想从我手里拿走这一瓶奶。
[主播] 白桃燕麦。
[主播] 啊？
[其他] 拍光了，我还可以喝。
[主播] 拍光了就还可以喝。
[其他] 对。
[主播] 厂家，不要让这这个酸奶拍光，答应我。
[主播] 最怕空气突然的安静，最怕导演突然的提醒。
[主播] 你说石门当今是咋把媳妇骗到手的，我就不能理解，他长成那个样子。
[其他] 可能是送了白桃味的酸奶。
[主播] 送了白桃味的酸奶。
[主播] 那一个每个人都着急长着翅膀要离开大学的日子里，迫不及待的一次次告别，相拥，在熟悉的走廊上，在曾经学习过的教室里，拍照留念。
[主播] 年轻人的每一次告别都显得如此的郑重，如此的充满仪式感。
[主播] 在每个人都恨不得立即离开校园的日子里，奇形怪状的石明，虽面目丑陋，但是他内心空洞。
[主播] 他可能把自己心中的美好，像这一罐白桃燕麦风味的酸奶一样，送给了当时年纪正好，心地善良，心地善良和心地善良的嫂子。
[主播] 人生有的时候啊，美好并不在于得偿所愿。
[主播] 美好往往在于阴差阳错。
[主播] 嫂子应该也可能想象过无数次一个白马王子，身材高大，帅气，才华横溢，风趣幽默，能够在篮球场上精准的投篮。
[主播] 能够在各种校园演唱会的现场，光彩照人。
[主播] 嫂子讲过很多。
[主播] 后来见到石门那一刻，强忍着胜利的不适，从他手里接过了紧张的微微颤抖着的那瓶认养一头牛的酸奶。
[主播] 在即将分别的时刻里，学校里显得兵荒马乱。
[主播] 石门激动的，手抖的地上那瓶酸奶显得无比的珍贵。
[主播] 今天我不关心世界的人，我只关心你。
[主播] 大概应该是这种类似的感动，让嫂子一时慌了阵脚。
[其他] 嫂子没准在看。
[主播] 失去了判断，嫂子再看，那这个认养一头牛这个酸奶啊。
[其他] 你你把两种口味都说一下，都喝。
[主播] 嫂子对不起，对不起，我我是想消费石门，我没想说你啊，我这个我刚说你都是正面形象，你是这个心地善良，心地善良，还有心地善良。
[主播] 石门，你知道石门的妻子长得特别漂亮，你知道吗？石门的孩子长得也很好看。
[主播] 在怀疑跟石门有关系没？
[主播] 啊？
[其他] 说太彻底了。
[主播] 有时候说的气人，这个是控糖低脂的啊。
[主播] 大概就是那种感觉吧。
[其他] 啥家庭喝酸奶不舔盖。
[主播] 像我喝酸奶只舔瓶盖，那到了。
[主播] 只舔瓶盖，开玩笑，开玩笑。
[主播] 正好喝的东西到哪到哪。
[主播] 里头白桃味的清新，燕麦咀嚼的口感，酸奶正好的浓度与甜。
[主播] 在大家即将散去的校园里，从紧张的手抖的石门手里接过那，看着这个面貌丑陋的男人，突然却有一丝心动的感觉。
[主播] 人生很多的遇见就是这样的突如其来。
[主播] 没有准备，你在心里排练过无数遍，应该是一个怎么样的一个时刻，怎么样英俊的少年，用怎么样优美的文字和动人的情书。
[主播] 但后来你慢慢没想到的，其实只是一个内心真实，见到你紧张的手抖脸红。
[主播] 甚至看了半天才发现他还有两只眼睛，手里拿着认养一头牛，白桃燕麦风味酸奶的少年。
[主播] 长得咋说呢？凑活这过吧，还能咋样？
[主播] 大家不懂，就是要现在人数最高的时候，在这里疯狂的营销石门。
[主播] 石门这俩天最大的愿望是什么？火。
[主播] 石门是一个非常。
[其他] 你只戳他的内心啊。
[主播] 石门现在一心求火。
[主播] 石门这俩天甚至看我的时候，眼睛里都怀着怒气。
[主播] 石门不能理解，长得都难看，凭啥你火，我不能火，哎不是我比你长得好看在哪的，凭啥我没火，石门大概就是这种感觉，不服气嘛，董辉你长得丑，那我也丑啊，你没文化，我也没文化呀，对不对？
[主播] 你性格差，我性格更差呀，对不对？
[主播] 凭什么你就火了，石门心里不服。
[主播] 所以我现在就要在石门间，直播间的人最多的时候，屡次提到石门。
[主播] 在大家看来，这个可能是消费石门。
[主播] 但是在石门看来。
[主播] 这是这个令人。
[主播] 不行，我不能再损他了。
[其他] 我们马上就可以喝酸奶了，还有2000单。
[主播] 还有2000单是吧？
[主播] 在在石门看来，这是令人感到兴奋的，不可多得的运气啊。
[其他] 黑火也是火。
[主播] 黑红也是红，啊。
[主播] 石门现在一心求火，只要能火，他愿意付出任何代价。
[主播] 真挺好喝的，白桃味，你试一试。
[其他] 还有1000单。
[主播] 啊？
[其他] 还有1000单，你再加加油。
[主播] 然后剩下这个我一会能带走吧？
[主播] 我装一下，厂家这箱要不我就不给你寄回去了，行不行？
[主播] 听话，你让我试一下。
[主播] 你让我也是一次在即将分别的校园里，穿过一个个操场，穿过一栋栋教学楼，穿过嘈杂拥挤的人群，微微激动地双手，拿着一瓶白桃燕麦风味的酸牛奶，酸奶。
[主播] 我先觉得我酸的跟个奶一样，我每次一提到石门有媳妇了，我就酸的跟这个奶一样。
[主播] 没出息，董辉你就是没出息，大笨蛋，大笨蛋咋喜欢那么久啊？
[主播] 我今天要把这个喝拿回去，我要把自己灌醉，猛男只能在深夜里流泪。
[主播] 你们都不懂。
[其他] 我帮你买。
[主播] 不用，我自己能拿回去。
[主播] 我这样的猛男必须在深夜里用酸奶把自己灌醉。
[主播] 眼泪只能留给自己。
[主播] 见证我眼泪的只有月光跟我，还有我的影子，这个世界只有三个人。
[主播] 哎，你知道天知地知你知我知，这话谁说的吗？
[主播] 西汉一个宰相叫杨震。
[主播] 杨震呢就是我老家同关人。
[主播] 他来做宰相之后呢，学生去找他，老师给我点钱，你给我一个官职，他说不行，我怎么能受贿呢？学生说这没人知道，老师说怎么没人知道，杨震说怎么没人知道，天知地知，你知我知，四个人都知道了。
[其他] 行了，666666666。
[主播] 所以就了天知地知你知我知这一说，知道吧？
[主播] 杨震，震震这个上面一个雨，下面那个臣的那个震，嗯。
[主播] 朋友说猛男的头必须是方的吗？
[主播] 这个倒不是猛男的必要条件啊，充分不必要。
[主播] 方方头可以是猛男，圆头也可以是猛男。
[主播] 猛男主要的特点是敢于直面自己惨淡的人生，敢于在自己照镜子的时候，仍然夸自己很帅。
[主播] 敢于在自己心碎的时候，给自己内心安慰，这个是猛男。
[主播] 跟头和脸没什么关系啊。
[主播] 来，下一个是什么？两款坚果。
[主播] 坚果是吧？
[其他] 这个量不多，简单吃两口。
[主播] 简单吃两口，量不多。
[主播] 哎，这个还是那个什么阿帕的松子是吧？
[主播] 阿帕的松子特点就是皮特别薄，你看跟瓜子一样，一捏就开了。
[主播] 然后松子这个颗粒又很大，咬起来满满的这个油脂的香味。
[主播] 我一看到这个松子，我想起以前在暑假在这个外婆外公家。
[主播] 他们因为在秦岭的山里，一个小小小村庄。
[主播] 大家家里做饭都是烧柴火，山上又经常那种枯死的干枯的松树。
[主播] 干枯的松树啊，特别容易燃烧，因为它有松油嘛。
[主播] 燃烧的时候会散发出一种非常浓的松油香。
[主播] 浓浓的松油香啊，从烟筒里飘出去。
[主播] 山间的风吹过来，松油的香飘向远方。
[主播] 我经常会山上取松树上抓一些那个不是抓一些，是摘一些那个松松塔。
[主播] 就或者叫松果，然后埋在做完菜的，烧完火的那个热的灰里头。
[主播] 你不能直接用火烧，因为烧可能就烧坏了，烧糊了，因为那个热的灰去捂一下。
[主播] 传统我们的松子其实皮很厚，因为里头有空嘛，所以烧着烧着，突然就爆炸了。
[主播] 每次我在院子里玩，然后厨房里的很热的炉灰里，像鞭炮一样偶尔发出非常震耳的声音。
[主播] 小时候生活就是那样的快乐，外婆也不骂我，好像是捣乱的，他也不说我，你喜欢你就去弄。
[主播] 虽然那些松子到最后大粉都烧糊了，也没法吃其实。
[主播] 但是自己不厌其烦，外婆也从来不责备。
[主播] 这个松子皮很薄，一剥就开，你看我跟剥瓜子一样。
[主播] 你们小时候有那个包裹松子吗？
[其他] 没有，我想试试。
[主播] 给。
[其他] 给他也拿一点。
[其他] 他有那个香妃，我没吃过这个。
[主播] 没吃过是吧？
[其他] 香妃。
[主播] 我也没吃过，没有。
[其他] 屏幕前的同学们吃过吗？
[主播] 给，你把那全部拿走。
[主播] 香妃是用盐，我也不知道这是个啥东西。
[主播] 哎呀。
[主播] 有点像那个巴旦木呀，是吧？
[主播] 嗯，椒香味扑鼻。
[主播] 那个八蛋木呀。
[主播] 是吧？
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 焦香味扑鼻。
[主播] 咸咸的，油油的。
[主播] 还挺好吃的。
[主播] 没吃过你可以尝一次啊。
[主播] 试一下。
[主播] 口感还挺棒的。
[嘉宾] 好香啊，焦香。
[主播] 你知道我们接下来会吃到更多好东西吗？
[主播] 或者会见到更多好东西吧？
[主播] 今天晚上。
[主播] 我刚去见于老师了。
[主播] 我们接下来会
[主播] 走全国。
[主播] 走更多的地方。
[主播] 把每一个 走遍每一片土地。
[主播] 寻找属于每片土地上特殊的味道。
[主播] 我们会去找很多地方的特产。
[主播] 然后在这儿找给大家。
[主播] 我们也希望用这种方式让大家记住更多的地方。
[主播] 发现更多的初级的农产品。
[主播] 让更多的当地人受益。
[主播] 很快就到了。
[主播] 大家等我们一段时间。
[主播] 我听完之后还是很激动的。
[主播] 我觉得终于可以做一些 让我们走出这栋楼的事情了。
[主播] 我我以前当老师，我的活动范围主要是教室那么大。
[主播] 但一天我还能走上一些距离。
[主播] 我现在当了主播之后，我的活动范围就是镜头前。
[主播] 而且左右晃荡的幅度还不能太大。
[主播] 除了站一天以外，基本上不怎么动。
[主播] 半只羊。
[主播] 喜欢的朋友可以自己去拍了啊，这个是冷链发货，对吧？
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 冷链发货。
[主播] 我给你展示这半只，你收到不是这个样子，我只是跟你说，它是半只羊去 拆出来的，一共十斤啊。
[主播] 因为小羊它都比较轻，羊不可能说几百斤啊。
[主播] 羊一般三四十斤都已经，五六十斤都已经很大了，三四十斤是正常的羊。
[主播] 然后你去掉肚子里那些内脏啥的。
[主播] 去掉皮毛和血。
[主播] 其实剩下的肉可能就是那一些。
[主播] 因为这个是高羊，它基本就是半年左右的。
[主播] 口感特别好啊。
[主播] 想吃的朋友自己去拍啊。
[主播] 有朋友说来我的甘肃。
[主播] 老人家甘肃。
[主播] 我特别喜欢西北，我去过很多次西北。
[主播] 我不知道我给你们讲过没？
[主播] 我们有一年去
[主播] 阿拉善。
[主播] 看胡杨林。
[嘉宾] 胡杨林。
[主播] 额济纳。
[主播] 你这额济纳，就是当年张艺谋拍英雄那个地方。
[主播] 有一片胡杨林，它不是张曼玉跟章子怡打斗吗？
[主播] 在漫天黄叶中飞舞记得吧？
[主播] 他们穿着红色衣服，唰甩出去。
[主播] 因为老谋子当年他是学美术的，他是学美工出身的。
[主播] 所以你看他的画面，颜色搭配会非常精致，发现的没？
[主播] 就他的画面永远给人震撼感，然后他的颜色搭配都非常的花心思。
[主播] 我们当年就想去看那个。
[主播] 一路开车开着开车。
[主播] 然后走到一个小的路上，我那个朋友问。
[主播] 他看不清楚我这边，他说能从这拐不？
[主播] 我说可以。
[主播] 结果我我就没有看我跟胡大应，然后车直接掉一个坑里了。
[主播] 一个沙子的坑，很软，车轮一跑呢，更加走不出去了。
[主播] 但是车底下把车顶起来，底盘，就轮胎陷空了嘛。
[主播] 我们就在那很久很久，一直走不了。
[主播] 天也很热。
[主播] 水喝完了。
[主播] 当时我一激动，我都差一点提，要不然咱互相喝彼此的尿吧。
[主播] 因为我印象中好像那些 那些荒野逃生的人，到最后一个办法就是喝尿。
[主播] 要不然渴死。
[主播] 我说万一渴死咋办？
[主播] 他说你现在渴不？
[主播] 我说我不渴。
[主播] 他说那等一会再喝。
[主播] 就行。
[主播] 我们还打了电话给他。
[主播] 那车里不是求救电话吗？
[主播] 然后别人问在哪？
[主播] 我们在沙漠里。
[主播] 沙漠啥地方？
[主播] 沙漠吗？
[主播] 一几年了这？
[主播] 一
[主播] 一六年，一六年十月。
[主播] 好多年前。
[主播] 实在不行了。
[主播] 最后真的开始渴了。
[主播] 然后车里头的吃的全都是一些饼干那种，越吃越越渴的东西。
[主播] 然后呢，想去旁边找这个，人来救我们，根本找不到。
[主播] 周围啥都没有，就是黄沙。
[主播] 你还看到遥远的那个热气腾腾的那个骆驼慢慢的在走。
[主播] 啥都没有。
[主播] 我们终于最后等等等，远远的驶来一队车队。
[主播] 迎风车顶的红旗猎猎而动，上面写着阿拉善英雄大会。
[主播] 十一，当时。
[主播] 一群人，大车就开过来，然后我当时想，我我得拦下。
[主播] 这样伸出我的腿，露出我的丝袜，那种感觉。
[主播] 大哥救命！
[主播] 然后大哥很爽快，唰车停我面前跳下来。
[主播] 兄弟，咋子来？
[主播] 我一听，哎呀。
[主播] 大哥，我我们车子陷在这儿。
[主播] 哎呀，我尝试用大哥的这个 这个强调说话。
[主播] 大哥应该是一个重庆人。
[主播] 大哥很爽快。
[主播] 跳下来，蹲在地上看一下，这车卡住了。
[主播] 然后就拿那个挂钩挂在车上，然后给后面拽着，一辆接一辆车，更多的车，然后就大哥往后一退，把我们车就拉出来了。
[主播] 拉出来之后，大哥，感谢你。
[主播] 大哥很淡定。
[主播] 我说大哥，感谢你。
[主播] 大哥说没事。
[主播] 我当时想半天给他啥呢？
[主播] 我说又没有啥。
[主播] 摸了200块钱。
[主播] 大哥说不要。
[主播] 大哥很爽快。
[主播] 问我们还有水喝没？
[主播] 他看我们嘴都起皮了。
[主播] 我说没有。
[主播] 大哥又给了我们两瓶水。
[主播] 然后转身就迅速把那个绞盘收起来，跳上自己车，一圈人，说，十几辆那个车又走了。
[主播] 车上面那个红旗猎猎而动，上面写个阿拉善英雄大会。
[主播] 从那以后我就特别喜欢去西北。
[主播] 我觉得江湖里头一定能遇到豪杰。
[主播] 我们后来到了那个阿拉善的时候，但是那个那个不在宁夏啊。
[主播] 然后就吃了很多的这个羊肉。
[主播] 就他们的羊就很好吃。
[主播] 直接就水一煮，放点盐就行了。
[主播] 然后就是，也煮完就是凉的，直接拿着吃都行。
[主播] 手抓肉，特别爽。
[主播] 再剥个蒜，哎呀。
[主播] 当然不一定每个人都喜欢蒜啊。
[主播] 真好吃。
[主播] 真爽。
[主播] 从那以后我就特别喜欢去西北。
[主播] 特别喜欢去吃肉。
[主播] 喝酒。
[主播] 遇见那些豪爽的 仗义相助的大哥。
[主播] 这个羊。
[主播] 大家也可以在自己家里感受一下。
[其他] 一个人跟大家再说一下的问。
[主播] 十斤。
[主播] 两斤的羊前腿。
[主播] 两斤的羊后腿。
[主播] 两斤的羊蝎子，还有两斤的羊排。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 羊小腿也两斤，一共加起来十斤。
[主播] 然后也送大家那些炖肉的料。
[主播] 人类简史适合初三学生吗？
[主播] 当然适合。
[主播] 人类简史可以读的。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 所以后来我就特别喜欢去这个西北。
[主播] 每次我去的时候，我都希望，哎，我今天车别再卡一次。
[主播] 会不会还有个大哥来救我？
[主播] 我特别喜欢感觉感觉那种好卖之气。
[主播] 并不过多于你交谈。
[主播] 但是极其热心肠，跳下来之后，绞盘给你一收，把你拉出来之后，绞盘绞盘取出来，迅速把你拉出来，绞盘一收，然后开着，十几辆车迅速的就走了。
[主播] 然后大哥走得很爽快。
[主播] 只有车上那个红旗猎猎而动。
[主播] 英雄大会。
[主播] 我差不多也算一个了吧？
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 小英雄。
[主播] 大哥一波云天。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 大概就是那种感觉。
[主播] 来这个羊喜欢自己去拍啊，自己去拍。
[主播] 朋友说，说不定大哥也在看直播。
[主播] 那我不知道，我不知道。
[主播] 大哥，如果你在直播间吗？
[主播] 在直播间。
[主播] 我们下次相遇啊。
[主播] 但是我估计可能悬吧，因为
[主播] 我现在都记不住他长什么样子。
[主播] 但是很庆幸的是。
[主播] 我觉得人在那个你遇到困难的异乡，谢谢谢谢，可能很重啊，在遇到困难的异乡，有一个人那样愿意豪爽的去帮你。
[主播] 我后来就觉得有一种 真的江湖上遇见了 英雄豪杰的那种豪迈之感。
[主播] 我还是很喜欢那种感觉的。
[主播] 看，谢谢，谢谢。
[主播] 来。
[主播] 小龙虾。
[主播] 真的是胶地板的直播间。
[主播] 这么多年朴素惯了。
[主播] 当年直播间里只有300来人的时候，样品总是舍不得用。
[主播] 我们又不好意思收人这个坑位费。
[主播] 样品也不好意思多要。
[主播] 每次就是一点样品反复用，用用几个星期。
[其他] 我们当时播你像我们只剩盒子了。
[主播] 对。
[主播] 我们当时播到最后很多盒子其实都是空的，没有办法给大家展示样品。
[主播] 不好意思要。
[主播] 总觉得自己没给人卖多少钱，一直要人东西。
[主播] 自己脸红。
[主播] 但是卖小龙虾，我记得我们那盘小龙虾都放馊了都。
[主播] 我跟悠悠连续播了四天，那小龙虾那第四天都馊了。
[其他] 我在提示你别吃，别吃。
[主播] 别吃别吃。
[主播] 还是播了一个塞嘴里去了。
[主播] 小龙虾其实如果你新鲜拆出来挺好吃的。
[主播] 但我们放四天已经放馊了。
[主播] 悠悠一播，闻着是馊的，递给了我。
[主播] 我说悠悠，你知道我这小龙虾过敏的。
[主播] 悠悠还迟疑的看了一下，啥意思？
[主播] 就这说你还不接受，对吗？
[主播] 然后悠悠想了半天，那个小龙虾肉又放进了盘子里。
[主播] 第二天是石棉直播。
[主播] 没事，反正石棉这个身体素质比较好。
[主播] 虽然石棉个人素质比较低，但身体素质确实比较好。
[其他] 石棉马上就来了。
[主播] 马上就来了，我现在已经开始替石棉做铺垫了。
[主播] 石棉马上就火了。
[主播] 黑红也是红。
[主播] 跟导演说得对。
[主播] 节俭惯了，你知道吗？
[主播] 现在有时候看着样品，不好意思吃。
[主播] 不好意思用。
[主播] 苦惯了。
[主播] 突然有了好日子过不了。
[主播] 现在直播间里34万人。
[其他] 这个不能吃。
[主播] 这个也是坏的是吧？
[其他] 你手下。
[主播] 啊，对对对对对，这个不能吃。
[主播] 对不起，我得吃小龙虾有点过敏。
[主播] 我一吃我可能一会，我吃完香肠嘴了，还说不清楚。
[主播] 但是我吃过那个奥龙和那个波士顿龙虾是可以的。
[其他] 不知道，你说你过敏是你跟我们说。
[主播] 我吃这个确实会肿。
[主播] 就是香肠嘴。
[主播] 但是我吃那些我发现只是有一点点是会痒，但是没太大事。
[其他] 就我们规格不够呗。
[主播] 不是不是。
[主播] 我可能也是你阶段性的问题，有的时候就反应特别大，有的时候就还好。
[主播] 就只是肿或者痒。
[主播] 有的时候用，或者哗哗的流口水那种，有一次。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 可能也是跟当时身体状态有关吧。
[主播] 少了一个人间的快乐呀。
[主播] 但是你记得前几天那一次我吃，我好像还吃了几个呢。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 就没啥事。
[主播] 不敢，不敢冒险。
[主播] 我现在。
[其他] 公司财富，不能随便。
[主播] 我我现在我的身体已经是公司财富了。
[主播] 我先必须要对公司负责。
[主播] 我现在可不能胡吃。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 万一吃坏了，公司得蒙受多大损失啊？
[其他] 要怪就怪小龙虾不懂事。
[主播] 小龙虾不懂事。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 小龙虾是一种。
[主播] 很美好的食物。
[主播] 因为到了夏天啊，你想象一下那种 人头攒动的。
[主播] 人来人往的街道。
[主播] 灯很亮。
[主播] 然后呢，大家相聚一堂。
[主播] 夜风一开始很热，吹着吹着慢慢变凉。
[主播] 然后大家倒的那个啤酒杯上，凝结的水珠沿着这个瓶子流下去。
[主播] 剥着的小龙虾。
[主播] 好久未见，你我促膝长谈。
[主播] 朋友啊。
[主播] 你曾去过远方。
[主播] 你曾有流浪。
[主播] 现在我们靠着这一瓶酒和这一盘小龙虾，互诉衷肠。
[主播] 下次再出发。
[主播] 我们要一起去远方。
[主播] 小龙虾。
[主播] 社交神器。
[主播] 适合朋友聊天。
[主播] 你朋友现在36万人看你一个人啥概念？
[主播] 没有啥感觉。
[主播] 我我我没有啥感觉。
[主播] 对不起，我清个嗓子，我关一下这个，好吗？
[其他] 我这边控制就行。
[其他] 上面好。
[主播] 好了好了。
[主播] 现在好了好了。
[主播] 不好意思，我我我这个还没喝完的，我不能浪费那么多样品。
[主播] 我曾经在一开始教教书那会。
[主播] 我记得当时那个班是12个，12个人。
[主播] 我给大家讲讲为什么我一般在感觉到别人骂我的时候，我其实不会有太多的迁怒呢？
[主播] 因为可能跟职业经历相关。
[主播] 我曾经是老师啊。
[主播] 如果学生冲我发脾气，我能冲学生去发回句脾气吗？
[主播] 不合理的。
[主播] 没有理由。
[主播] 我当时在新东方教的第一个班很尴尬。
[主播] 是一个老师，他教了一半突然离开了。
[主播] 然后呢，可能因为一些不太开心的原因嘛，他离开了。
[主播] 离开之前呢，传递了一些不太好的这个信息给学生。
[主播] 所以我在第一次上那个班的，给那个班去上课的时候，我明显的一节课能感觉到非常强烈的敌意。
[主播] 就是我站在前面，我在很激动的讲。
[主播] 但是没有一个人在听我。
[主播] 第一排有个女生。
[主播] 就是他全全程课，他就板着脸，一直拿书这样啪啪啪就是摔着，发出噪音。
[主播] 他后来可能摔累了，他又开始。
[主播] 就一直大声在咳嗽。
[主播] 我们是一节课两小时。
[主播] 前面几课是一小时。
[主播] 其他同学其实一开始也在捣乱。
[主播] 但我在前面那样讲。
[主播] 他一直前一小时一直在这样，摔书这样子。
[主播] 他其实根本不想听我讲。
[主播] 我能理解他可能当时内心有很多愤怒，或者有很多的不舒服。
[主播] 我其实能理解他。
[主播] 我我能理解那个孩子可能当时不开心。
[主播] 其实我最容易做的事情就是骂他，我说你不听你滚出去，对吗？
[主播] 但我知道如果我这样做的话，我可能会 让这个孩子误入歧途的。
[主播] 他那刻只是想要特别强烈的表达自己的一些情绪而已。
[主播] 如果我当时用特别糟糕的态度对了它，他可能以后就。
[主播] 我在担心他会不会就因此变得叛逆了。
[主播] 所以我就忍着。
[主播] 我在那儿还是在讲。
[主播] 我还提醒他们去做笔记。
[主播] 我还把笔记他们做不全，我把黑板分成两半，把一半专门写成提纲。
[主播] 那时候我还很年轻。
[其他] 你那会当老师。
[主播] 我那那会当老师，我也没太多经验，我没处理过那种情况。
[主播] 我其实一直很紧张。
[主播] 我在那讲的时候，我把一个手一直放在口袋里装酷，其实是紧张到手抖，手心一直在出汗。
[主播] 我特别不想伤害他，但是我也不知道怎么处理那种情况。
[其他] 这种情况。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 然后。
[主播] 然后在课间休息的时候。
[主播] 如果我是一个很玻璃心的老师，我应该出去第一时间去找教务，我说这个班我不带了。
[主播] 或者这个班学生我带不了，你自己想办法。
[主播] 我可以把锅甩给别人。
[主播] 或者我去把那个孩子拉出来，你别想听，你别捣乱了，别在这里烦我，我可以用很糟糕的态度，很轻蔑的语气和很嘲讽的措辞去伤害他。
[其他] 这不应该。
[主播] 但我能理解一个学生他能有多坏啊？
[主播] 他能有多大恶意？
[主播] 他一定是因为有一些特殊的委屈而已。
[主播] 所以我出来找了一个杯子。
[主播] 我接了一杯水。
[主播] 热水。
[主播] 我接完之后我发现不行。
[主播] 他万一真的是咳嗽呢？
[主播] 他万一真的是嗓子不舒服呢？
[主播] 他万一不全是在捣乱呢？
[主播] 我又从阿姨那块要了一罐那个那个就是京都念慈庵那个冲的东西。
[主播] 因为老师一般上课他都给老师会常备那些。
[主播] 我就给他冲了一杯水，搅开之后我进去送给他。
[主播] 说孩子，我刚刚看你咳嗽了一节课，你可能是嗓子不太舒服。
[主播] 这个可能有点用，因为平时我也会这样喝。
[主播] 我把那个杯子放他面前的时候，那个孩子本来在啪啪摔的书突然就停下来了。
[主播] 我说如果你 不太舒服的话。
[主播] 也可以我让阿姨给你找一些其他的药。
[主播] 我我只是希望你能够身体健康一些。
[主播] 那个孩子突然就不说话了，也不开始也不摔了，也不咳嗽了，他就沉默了。
[主播] 然后头抬起来。
[主播] 很认真的看着我，看了很久也没有说话，我也没有说话，他也没有说话。
[主播] 你这个酸梅汤喜欢的朋友去拍。
[主播] 这个是新远斋的，你应该是知道的，很经典。
[主播] 还有这个五香鸡。
[主播] 可以吃这个烧鸡。
[主播] 然后我我有一万个理由冲他发怒。
[主播] 我有一万个理由用更加糟糕的态度去说他，批评他。
[主播] 而且我有理由相信，就算我当天把他家长叫来，他家长来了也一定会去批评孩子，会站在我这边。
[主播] 因为毕竟是孩子不对在先的。
[主播] 我越是有理由那么做的时候，我越不能那么做，因为我不能站在一个强势的道德高点上去指责一个。
[主播] 不知道怎么表达自己情绪的年轻人。
[主播] 我把那个水放那之后，那个孩子瞬间就不闹了。
[主播] 然后孩子还很认真把那个水拿起来。
[主播] 还喝了一口。
[主播] 他说谢谢老师。
[主播] 我嗓子不渴了。
[主播] 从因为那个课间没有一个人出去。
[主播] 因为大家可能都想忍完我那一节课，他们下节课立马就要退掉这个课，不上了，永远不上了。
[主播] 我特别害怕如果我当时处理不好的话，会不会伤害到他们学习的积极性？
[主播] 或者让他们因此变成个叛逆的人？
[主播] 或者让他们学以后生活中只要处理不好情绪的时候，他们都用这种特别糟糕的态度与别人产生敌对。
[主播] 我特别害怕。
[主播] 所以。
[主播] 我虽然当时也很紧张，我手都在抖，因为我当时是个没有经验的老师，新老师。
[主播] 但我觉得爱和温暖始终能是感化一个人的。
[主播] 我把那个水放在他的桌子边。
[主播] 那那后半节课他们听得非常认真。
[主播] 没有一个人捣乱。
[主播] 大家都在认真的听，然后在做笔记。
[主播] 还开始回答问题，还举手，你知道吗？
[主播] 我在下面这课越讲我就越开心，越讲我越笑，越讲我越开心的就笑。
[主播] 我当时脸上就控制不住的笑容。
[主播] 我当时觉得。
[主播] 我当时觉得我做的真的很好。
[主播] 我觉得我或者我觉得我那天处理的方法是对的。
[主播] 然后那天下了课之后，我往楼下走的时候，有个学生冲上来，老师，说。
[主播] 学生给了我一个棒棒糖。
[主播] 是坐在最后一排，一开始踢凳子的那个学生。
[主播] 还是个女同学。
[主播] 12个人的班。
[主播] 那个班后来把他们带到高三毕业，重考都特别好。
[主播] 他们后来跟我分享很多生活中的故事。
[主播] 然后那个女生现在在，后来去英国读书了。
[主播] 直到现在有时候还会跟我经常发一些消息。
[主播] 拍。
[主播] 他们后来跟我分享很多生活中的故事。
[主播] 然后那个女生现在在后来去英国读书了，直到现在有时候还会跟我经常发一些消息。
[主播] 我那会儿特别年轻啊，我好像在自己的教学法里一直得到了培训都是关于怎么把课讲清楚。
[主播] 好像在我人生原有的经历里头，从来没有会意料到突然出来那么一出超过我知识范围以外的情况。
[主播] 那刻我只是坚守了一个自己内心认为对的方向，就是
[主播] 用爱和温暖去感化每一个人。
[主播] 只要出了问题，肯定是我没有处理好，或者我应该能处理好的。
[主播] 所以，这就是你职业里头的习惯，你的过去会形成现在的你，你现在的你也会去决定未来的你。
[主播] 所以当一般在骂我，误会我的时候，其实
[主播] 我的第一反应并不是生气。
[主播] 我的第一反应也并不是与他去争辩，我觉得没有必要。
[主播] 我应该像当年感化那个学生一样，哈哈。
[主播] 去感化这些人，我觉得应该是可以的，嗯。
[主播] 他只是因为不理解你而已，仅此而已。
[嘉宾] 有朋友说老师大美新疆竟然不送。
[主播] 可能是因为太远了，他可能运费实在扛不住。
[主播] 因为运费，大家可能不太理解，比如说像现在这个季节去送一些冷链的东西，运费成本非常高。
[主播] 非常高，甚至有时候补贴到
[主播] 最后可能就没有利润了。
[嘉宾] 但是大家如果有售后问题的话，还是可以私下联系我。
[主播] 对，但不管我们这个过程受了什么，但你有售后问题，第一时间请联系我们。
[主播] 一定对此负责到底，好吧。
[主播] 联系完了之后，你不爽，你想骂我两句也可以，但是我一定得把你这个东西该换的换，该退的退，该赔的赔了。
[主播] 嗯，一定会负责到底的啊。
[主播] 请大家收到任何的问题，第一时间先联系这个商家，因为我们卖的很多东西其实是商家，也不是我们的。
[主播] 你联系他，如果联系他他没有给你解决，你联系我，我一定会追责到底。
[主播] 我自己先给你赔，我先赔了，我再去解决其他的事情就行，好吧。
[主播] 但我们我们工作这么长时间以来，其实发现遇到的都是一些特别好的商家。
[主播] 都是特别好的商家，没有遇见过的，比如说就是对自己的产品应是不负责的人。
[主播] 我刚为什么突然会想到讲那一段呢？
[主播] 就是我其实想告诉你，遇件一些生活中糟糕的事情的时候，你不一定非要用针尖对麦芒。
[主播] 还有一个就是今天因为刚好出来了，我知道屏幕前可能今天有一些孩子们心情不是特别开心。
[主播] 可能是上过我课的高三的学生。
[主播] 第一个，不用太去纠结。
[主播] 人生是一场马拉松。
[主播] 用跑马拉松的心态去看你这一生。
[主播] 智力能解决的都是短期问题。
[主播] 中期拼的是毅力，长期拼的是体力。
[主播] 还有一个就是
[主播] 得到的是幸运。
[主播] 错过的可能才是人生。
[主播] 人生的美好不一定在于得偿所愿。
[主播] 恰恰相反，很多时候更多时候好在于阴差阳错。
[主播] 要不是阴差阳错，我当年也不会去西外。
[主播] 不是阴差阳错，我也不会选择当时根本没有希望的，新东方的工作的岗位。
[主播] 不是阴差阳错，我也不会在19年选择来北京找孙老师。
[主播] 不是阴差阳错的去年那段时间。
[主播] 其实我当时真的想
[主播] 一走了之。
[主播] 而且因为其实高中课很多地方还能还能上，我我我当时看其实也有一些出路。
[主播] 但就是因为那会大家都很难。
[主播] 我那当时觉得大家这么难，我好像是一个给前线送粮食，送水的一个
[主播] 补给的一个人员一样。
[主播] 如果在那时候我自私的走了，我会不会以后特别愧疚，然后不知道怎么以后见他们，怎么跟他们聊天。
[主播] 我在想的内块。
[主播] 所以后来就坚守下来了。
[主播] 人生很多时候可能遇见的是绝境。
[主播] 但是你再走一走就柳暗花明了。
[主播] 我跟石明其实那段时间我们俩都是。
[主播] 我呢长得非主流。
[主播] 石明呢长得杀马特。
[嘉宾] 杀马特。
[主播] 非主流加杀马特，而且呢还都不是很有天分。
[主播] 当时在直播每次播完了之后，其实就很难受嘛。
[主播] 我跟什么人我们俩就从公司这里走到
[嘉宾] 你俩应该没少一起喝酒吧。
[主播] 人那什么，其实那会喝酒喝的也不多。
[主播] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 雨灰的酒量主要不行，他就是一杯老早，就倒了。
[嘉宾] 喝喝不了。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 然后呢，对，我一杯一杯酸奶就倒了其实。
[主播] 你不能夸大还口，不能打误会。
[主播] 啊。
[嘉宾] 酸奶你才是误导的，你老早会会有点有点度数，你那酸奶是什么？
[主播] 我现在我们俩当时就从这个
[嘉宾] 你喝那酸奶坏了，发酵了。
[主播] 差不多，啊。
[主播] 从这块一直走回到这个人大西门那块，我们当然合租那个小区里。
[主播] 旁边是一个垃圾堆。
[主播] 小区外面是一个垃圾堆。
[主播] 那个窗户我从来都没有敢开过，因为开窗户就臭。
[主播] 但我不知道为什么，因为是在一楼吧可能。
[主播] 房间里也全是蚊子。
[主播] 特别难。
[嘉宾] 我觉得就是你命也不行。
[嘉宾] 就是那个房子我最早住着吧，它挺安宁的，你睡眠不好，然后你自从住到那，咱后边那个医院就一直开始装修施工。
[主播] 而且半夜。
[嘉宾] 半夜开始拉垃圾。
[嘉宾] 哐哐哐，天天施工。
[主播] 但我睡的就很好。
[嘉宾] 天天老他。
[主播] 我只要有光有声音，我都睡不着了。
[主播] 所以那段时间呢，我们俩也熬过来了。
[主播] 终于有机会见到大家，很开心啊，今晚。
[嘉宾] 你正在给大家介绍什么啊？
[主播] 我刚才介绍啥？
[嘉宾] 介绍的是
[主播] 三没烫。
[嘉宾] 三没烫，三没烫。
[嘉宾] 然后还有到整点，那个武昌黑米再给大家来一点。
[嘉宾] 你别着急走，刚老板给我叮咛了，说你先不着急下班。
[嘉宾] 就是还得再播一会。
[主播] 为啥？
[主播] 谁说的？
[嘉宾] 就是老板。
[主播] 哪个？
[主播] 我现在要当面对峙。
[嘉宾] 你现在气质这么硬啊？
[主播] 不是，你谁叫聪明，你得问清楚谁？
[嘉宾] 真的不骗你啊。
[主播] 老孙还是老鱼？
[嘉宾] 就是让你再播一会。
[嘉宾] 他们说不能让你走。
[主播] 我跟他们确认一下谁。
[嘉宾] 先这个黑米给大家介绍一下啊。
[嘉宾] 这是作为一个福利品，今天呢咱们是几块钱呀？
[主播] 18块8。
[嘉宾] 18块8，这是一个五斤装的。
[主播] 五斤装的。
[嘉宾] 五斤装的黑米啊。
[嘉宾] 品质还挺好的，大家呢喜欢的话可以来黑米来。
[嘉宾] 主要是什么是，就是今天大家最近不是一直被顿顿在哄睡吗？
[嘉宾] 在哄睡，各种老公哄睡。
[主播] 顿顿是这个开心的入睡。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 然后咱俩坐在镜头前，大家就是心情焦虑的，惶恐的。
[嘉宾] 不不，但你在其实效果还是好一点。
[嘉宾] 如果单独是我，效果就会很差。
[主播] 绵绵对不起，我还是
[嘉宾] 我还是想给屏幕前的这些朋友说一下，我相信你们能入这个坑，来到东方甄选这块呢，更多的是因为我们的方老师，因为我们董老师来的。
[嘉宾] 但是来了以后呢，可能被顿顿这个老公给吸纳过去了。
[嘉宾] 既然是冲着老师来的，到这又遇见了老公，我觉得你也不妨，或者你也不会特别介意再多一个老铁。
[主播] 还是挺介意的，挺介意的。
[主播] 交朋友也得谨慎，我不能没有原则。
[嘉宾] 再多一个老铁，也喜欢喜欢我，也容纳一下，我觉得问题应该不是很大。
[主播] 交你这样的朋友何必呢？啊。
[嘉宾] 啊，黑米没了。
[主播] 黑米没了。
[嘉宾] 6000单，马上就没了。
[主播] 这么快。
[嘉宾] 五公斤，然后加了，那是咱们的福利品。
[嘉宾] 啊，行了，我我不逗你了吧。
[嘉宾] 这个是这样，咱俩一块给大家介绍一下咱们陕西的油泼面。
[嘉宾] 介绍完之后你就可以休息了，好不好？
[主播] 好，啊。
[嘉宾] 来，下面呢给大家介绍一下来自于我们陕西的油泼面。
[嘉宾] 我俩这个长相一看大家就知道是陕西人又来了。
[嘉宾] 但这样说可能又引起咱们陕西那些帅哥们的一些不太合适。
[主播] 我们俩不能代表陕西。
[嘉宾] 咱俩是陕西的残次品属于是。
[主播] 对，陕西还是有很多的帅哥美女的。
[主播] 大家如果去一趟陕西，去一趟这个陕西哥哥的街道走一走，还是能发现有很多长相特别精致，气质特别
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 非凡的人。
[嘉宾] 是是是。
[主播] 我们俩在陕西里头属于这个残次品。
[主播] 可能说拖后腿吧，拖脚地板，脚后跟的。
[嘉宾] 残次品。
[嘉宾] 残次品啊。
[嘉宾] 但是呢，希望我俩的这个颜值不要影响了这一个好吃的这一口面，我们陕西的这个油泼面。
[主播] 上地相，对不起，对不起，我们俩不是故意长成这个样子的。
[主播] 不是故意长这个样子，对不起啊。
[主播] 不是给大家拖后腿了。
[主播] 这个陕西的
[嘉宾] 你俩也进行了一些努力，要不然也发展不到今天这个局面。
[嘉宾] 你不能光光怪先天的一些。
[主播] 其实没咋努力，坦诚来说。
[嘉宾] 我觉得努力也没啥用。
[主播] 很多人以为我这是脚病冷脚的，你听一下声音。
[主播] 这都是骨头帮硬的声音，啊。
[主播] 这属于天赋一柄。
[嘉宾] 你讲就给大家讲这个。
[主播] 几乎没有负重负重前行。
[主播] 陕西人吃面，你知道陕西啊。
[主播] 山西啊，对吧，包括河南。
[主播] 大家吃面真的是吃出了各种文化。
[主播] 我相信如果你看过很多跟陕西相关的电视，电影或者那些电视剧的作品里头，乔手的这个
[主播] 妈妈们一定会赶出非常劲道的面，对。
[主播] 然后呢在家里面那个赶仗碰撞着那个木案板。
[嘉宾] 你知道这都是这都是有要求的，它不是糊弄的。
[主播] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 就是就是揉面都是有要求的。
[嘉宾] 我小时候呢，家里人还给我讲过。
[主播] 手要光，面要光，盆要光。
[嘉宾] 对。
[嘉宾] 揉面要讲三光，手光、面光和盆光，这样才是比较合适的。
[主播] 对。
[嘉宾] 然后再再扯的时候，拽的时候，摔的时候，也要讲究。
[主播] 那种清脆的声音，一是声音很大。
[嘉宾] 然后还要讲究它就是那个叫什么，接花，接发化，功夫要用上，才能让这个面呢更好一些。
[嘉宾] 然后煮的时候也是有要求。
[主播] 别别我们害怕。
[主播] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 煮的这个时候也要有要求，就是你你煮面条的时候。
[嘉宾] 我原来不理解，我说是为什么这个面煮开了。
[嘉宾] 他要加一次凉水。
[嘉宾] 然后又加一次凉水，再加凉，图什么呢？
[嘉宾] 那水锅一直开着不好吗？
[主播] 因为它就溢出来了。
[主播] 而且面熟不透嘛。
[嘉宾] 但是过了。
[嘉宾] 你这你这你你看人家这解释，你这解释的就不对。
[主播] 咋不对？
[嘉宾] 就是因为你要让它的那个快速的加半瓢凉水进去，让它的那个温度迅速的去骤降，然后慢慢的加热，骤降，加热，骤降，这样煮出来的面就会更加劲道。
[主播] 还有一个你不加那锅真的就溢出来了。
[嘉宾] 对对对对对。
[主播] 锅真的就溢出来了。
[主播] 这是最直接的原因。
[嘉宾] 对。
[嘉宾] 然后整个把面煮好之后，你知道它的精华和精髓是什么呢？就是在五月到六月这会。
[嘉宾] 咱们那小麦其实也刚收时间不长。
[主播] 刚收还得洗麦。
[主播] 摸还得洗面。
[嘉宾] 洗面。
[主播] 拉回到家里房里头。
[主播] 活面活的。
[嘉宾] 活面揉，三广记请了啊。
[嘉宾] 然后弄的时候，帅的时候。
[主播] 哎，一定要发声。
[嘉宾] 接花发，接花发这个这个功力要用出来。
[主播] 一定要发出声响。
[主播] 锅烧开了。
[主播] 这个开费。
[嘉宾] 天两天两次，一般天两次，然后三开，需要的时候你再。
[嘉宾] 如果很多人不习惯咱们陕西人吃面的方式，说你们这也没有菜啊，就放一点葱花。
[主播] 你可以你可以在
[嘉宾] 你可以再弄一点那个
[主播] 菜的过。
[嘉宾] 青菜，或者小菠菜什么之类的放上去，点缀一下。
[主播] 那个葱花点缀，那个葱花点缀一下。
[嘉宾] 点缀一下。
[嘉宾] 完了出锅之后，弄点葱花，把那个辣椒倒上去，这个时候要拿那个长柄的那个勺，那个勺一定要是长柄的。
[主播] 对。
[嘉宾] 就像这个，就像技巧熟练的烤烤鸭的工人从里头取出来那种，把油一定要烧到冒烟开始。
[嘉宾] 然后往上一浇，刺啦，刺啦那一生。
[主播] 你有点夸张了是吧？
[嘉宾] 你说是。
[嘉宾] 就是刺啦的那一生，然后你那口水是不是就留下来了？
[主播] 你是把油倒到你。
[主播] 你是把油倒到你腿上。
[主播] 你咋的？
[主播] 你咋倒油，你倒完油之后会会倒气。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 你是把油倒到你腿上吗？
[嘉宾] 不是。
[嘉宾] 就是那个很香。
[嘉宾] 这个时侯端着面一定不要在家里吃，把面端出去拿两个蒜坐到院子边上。
[嘉宾] 坐到院子边上，然后过来一个人，吃羊毛。
[主播] 吃羊毛。
[嘉宾] 你今年没收咋样嘛，下门。
[主播] 你俩叫胡扯。
[嘉宾] 8000单。
[主播] 还有多少？
[嘉宾] 这怎么能叫胡扯？
[嘉宾] 我们这是给大家还原生活现象。
[嘉宾] 对对对，咱继续把这点话，这太美好了。
[主播] 对。
[嘉宾] 就过来一个。
[主播] 你这个厂长也在看。
[主播] 他今天给我们加单了。
[嘉宾] 今年。
[主播] 厂长，赶快休息这么晚了。
[嘉宾] 哎呀，这怎么报喜不报忧是吧？娘娘，你你都来看来了，那你赶紧给咱多加点，咱这人多。
[嘉宾] 来继续啊。
[主播] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 你今年没收咋样嘛？
[主播] 哎，没今年收成。
[主播] 没你哼。
[嘉宾] 人面吃上，生活更幸福。
[主播] 生活更幸福。
[嘉宾] 你看他就是经过大量的这种体力劳动之后，身体需要很多这种碳水，所以要来这一碗面。
[主播] 迅速补充这个。
[嘉宾] 对，迅速补充。
[嘉宾] 带来的那种踏实和幸福，在丰收的喜悦以后。
[嘉宾] 然后五月的天气有点燥热，我觉得这会到你擅长的地方了，快。
[主播] 蝉鸣的下气。
[主播] 我要遇见你。
[嘉宾] 然后巷子里可能有几只狗在叫，在飞。
[主播] 哎对。
[嘉宾] 远处还有秦腔的声音就要起了，来唱唱唱去唱去。
[主播] 他大舅他二舅都是他舅。
[嘉宾] 高桌子地半等都是木头。
[主播] 请可大银可大还嫌不够。
[主播] 下句是啥？
[嘉宾] 啥你挖宝牛？
[主播] 天在山。
[嘉宾] 天在山，地在下，你挖宝牛。
[主播] 哎，就是。
[嘉宾] 你挖宝牛啊。
[主播] 对，你不要太太长，你不要太长。
[嘉宾] 你不要你不要太狂妄啊，就是这意思。
[嘉宾] 然后情切一起来，这碗用破面就下去了。
[嘉宾] 然后咱们今天给大家介绍的这个油泼面呢，大家已经买了8000单了。
[嘉宾] 我再补后边这个话。
[主播] 已经一万单了。
[嘉宾] 一万单了。
[嘉宾] 可能稍微有点晚，但是我还是要补充一下，这个面呢跟我们两个刚才描述的那个在口感上是有差异的。
[主播] 你是不是个渣男？
[主播] 你先告诉我。
[嘉宾] 这个给你再。
[主播] 你刚说这是。
[主播] 是在分享成功经验吗？就是纸片，从来不说是真实情况。
[嘉宾] 我先给大家说一下。
[主播] 嫂子在镜头下面。
[嘉宾] 我先给大家把这个说一下啊。
[主播] 嫂子。
[嘉宾] 嫂子应该也睡了。
[嘉宾] 哎呀，他要哄完了，你再别捣乱啊。
[主播] 嫂子。
[嘉宾] 这个面呢，它毕竟是做成这种袋装的，你回去煮，再用点辣椒去吃，它没有面馆里边的或者现做的那么好吃，坦诚的讲啊。
[嘉宾] 但是也能够未尽。
[主播] 你朋友说我懂了，马上就申请退款。
[嘉宾] 但是那也能为计一个。
[主播] 你收不了了，你收不了了。
[嘉宾] 厂家的库存。
[主播] 你看你以后挑主播是不是得挑一个这个靠谱的？
[主播] 你像石明这种货。
[主播] 整个做副工。
[嘉宾] 你要坦诚的给大家讲这个。
[主播] 是是，那我那我那我。
[嘉宾] 有一点点不一样，但是可以的。
[主播] 他肯定是不一样嘛。
[嘉宾] 能吃。
[主播] 也叫不一样。
[嘉宾] 你把这个买回去。
[主播] 放着豆芽子，放着青菜。
[嘉宾] 对，是这个面。
[主播] 我俩个蒜一赔，啊。
[嘉宾] 对，刚才谈到这个事了，我就我就给你聊一下。
[嘉宾] 你就要给他吃这个面，吃着吃着呢，你们可以端着这碗面，可以一起看日出。
[嘉宾] 可以一起看日落。
[嘉宾] 然后就可以一起看日子。
[嘉宾] 听吗？
[主播] 再再喝完面汤，人给你看了个日子。
[主播] 定了婚事。
[嘉宾] 还有500单了。
[主播] 嫂子你受苦了。
[嘉宾] 还有500单。
[主播] 嫂子你确实受苦了。
[主播] 我觉得你应该是翻回的权利。
[嘉宾] 我我我当初就是因为我。
[主播] 我觉得嫂子应该也是翻回的权利。
[嘉宾] 喝面汤喝的好。
[嘉宾] 定下来了。
[嘉宾] 他觉得家里的其他好像都不太喝面汤，然后我每次呢去。
[嘉宾] 大碗面整两碗，然后框框喝好多面汤，觉得这个娃很很实在。
[主播] 很水。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 你喝那么多汤应该很水。
[主播] 喝面汤跟实在真有啥关系？
[主播] 你不要在这里甩锅，好吧？
[主播] 有的朋友确实不喜欢喝面汤。
[主播] 这跟水不水确实没有什么关系。
[嘉宾] 咱采访一下吧，那个喜欢喝面汤的敲一波一。
[嘉宾] 不喜欢喝面汤的敲一波零。
[主播] 我想到一个段子。
[主播] 巴比，我要我要喝奶奶。
[主播] 火撒你过里又面汤，大概是这种感觉，是吧？
[主播] 火撒你过里又面汤。
[主播] 巴比我要看小星星那种。
[嘉宾] 那个那个本来原词是什么？巴比我要喝什么？原词是要喝什么？
[主播] 喝奶奶。
[嘉宾] 我要喝奶奶。
[主播] 火撒你过里又面汤。
[嘉宾] 啊，一万多单整完了，你看这喜欢喝面汤的多少？
[嘉宾] 你看看。
[嘉宾] 看看这这气派的排面。
[嘉宾] 哎呀。
[嘉宾] 原汤化原石。
[主播] 大家受苦了，大家受苦了。
[主播] 你们还是要保持理性，大家完全不应于自己。
[主播] 不要因为自己爱心的泛滥，来怜悯镜头前这两个灵长类的动物。
[主播] 啊，万物皆自由。
[主播] 我们俩能进化到今天，也是符合大自然规律的。
[主播] 大家花钱还是要谨慎，千万不能因为同情我们俩。
[嘉宾] 哎呀。
[主播] 就在这疯狂消费。
[主播] 不合理。
[主播] 你挣钱也不容易，你说是呢？
[嘉宾] 那个已经卖完了。
[主播] 你看石明不闹心吗？
[嘉宾] 下边。
[主播] 就想退单。
[嘉宾] 咱俩还能接着讲吗？
[主播] 放过，来放过。
[嘉宾] 下一本呢来给大家介绍一个好吃的，就是这个。
[嘉宾] 被本南瓜。
[主播] 我明天上午有班。
[嘉宾] OK，行了，你下班吧。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 现在人数40万。
[主播] 这胜势如你所愿。
[主播] 满意吗？
[嘉宾] 我我其实有一种技能。
[主播] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 就是可以让它在20分钟内掉到4万。
[主播] 掉到4万。
[主播] 我知道，你因为这个智商极低，所以破坏性强，又因为非常努力，所以破坏性极强。
[嘉宾] 对。
[嘉宾] 我就是比较努力，然后脑子又不够。
[嘉宾] 然后要人数掉的比较快。
[主播] 你不能这样说自己。
[主播] 因为太真实了。
[主播] 我忍不住会点赞的。
[嘉宾] 还是那句话，这个雨灰要走了。
[嘉宾] 雨灰走之后呢，大家这个。
[嘉宾] 你看大家现在说从明明这买主要是同情。
[嘉宾] 你们不要这样子。
[嘉宾] 然后呢，等会雨灰走了，大家就是退场的时候，一定要注意秩序。
[嘉宾] 咱们还是从最后一排，不要拥挤，不要产生踩踏。
[主播] 过班的班主任组织一下。
[嘉宾] 还是从最后一排，咱们有有秩序的，慢慢的去退。
[主播] 咱这个文明校园。
[嘉宾] 对，不要踩踏，不要呼一下这种。
[嘉宾] 好，行了，你可以你可以休息了。
[主播] 行了。
[主播] 兵马俑，我得回去站岗了。
[主播] 要不然我那个坑里头确实今天少了一天。
[嘉宾] 我怕你看不出来。
[嘉宾] 游客不习惯。
[主播] 游客如果看出来确实少一个坑的话，你说是票钱他花了不开心。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 我们陕西的。
[嘉宾] 关键尤其是你这个脸，就是又是第一排C位。
[主播] 对，又又非常的具有识别性。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 少的这个方脸大眼看出来。
[主播] 我们陕西的男人白天要出去打工挣钱，养活家人，给妻子买漂亮的裙子，给孩子买奶粉。
[主播] 到了晚上呢，必须拿着身份证排队去那里轮流站岗，守护2000年来那片土地上的尊严和希望。
[嘉宾] 你这话说的老惨了，好像媳妇把你怎么样，你是娶了个媳妇还是拜了个江湖大哥？
[主播] 你你不懂。
[主播] 这是我内心的执着的追求。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 说笑醒了，是这样。
[主播] 这个大家到晚上了，该休息就休息，不要太为难自己。
[主播] 石明老师呢，确实长得虽然像一场自然灾难，但是呢。
[主播] 他好歹有媳妇，你不用太同情他。
[主播] 你还是得心疼自己。